SUBSTANCES CONTROL TO ORDER AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME.
THE A CO CHAIRS OF THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES THAT ARE A
COMMITTEES THAT ARE HERE --
A GUY CHAIR QUIRK MY CASKEY AND
ALAN -- THIS
IS FAIRLY UNIQUE THAT WE HAVE --
THIS MANY COMMITTEES MEETING ON
ONE TOPIC I THINK GIVING AT
LEAST SOME INDICATION OF HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS I ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME THE MEMBERS OF THE
VARIOUS.
COMMITTEES WHO ARE HERE WITH US
IN WHO WILL BE ARRIVING DURING
THE COURSE OF THE MEETING.
pPIECE OF TESTIMONY THAT'S GOING
ON ELSEWHERE IN THE COUNTRY IF
YOU HAPPEN TO BE LOOKING AT YOUR
PHONE DURING THE MEETING I WILL
UNDERSTAND WHY --
THAT IS STILL GOING ON IS IT NOT --
THE DTS SEE SERVES A VERY --
VITAL FUNCTION WHICH IS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AND ENVIRONMENT
AND THE ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXIC
SUBSTANCES AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
UNFORTUNATELY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS DTS SEE HAS BEEN
PLAGUED WITH CONTROVERSY.
RANGING FROM FISCAL MANAGEMENT
ISSUES -- TO
AND INCONSISTENT ARE
INCONSISTENT RECORD KEEPING AND
SUFFICIENT ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES AND SOME LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY.
OF FOR EXAMPLE A STATE AUDIT ON
THAT THE TSC FAILED TO COLLECT
AN ESTIMATED ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN CLEANUP
COSTS.
FROM A POLLUTERS DATING BACK.
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN A
FAILED TO SEND OUT NEARLY A
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND BILLS.
AND FOR THE FIFTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSESSMENTS --
THE DTS EMAILED A BUT NEVER
COLLECTED.
THEN IN TWENTY FIFTEEN DETAILS
HE CAME UNDER FIRE FOR THE
DELAYED CLEAN UP OF THE EXIDE
BATTERY RECYCLING PLANT AND BURN
AND AFTER NEIGHBORS OF THE PLAN
COMPLAINED FOR YEARS ABOUT BEING
SICKENED.
BY LEAD AND ARSENIC.
COMMUNITY GROUPS TO LIVE NEAR
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES ARE
CONCERNED THAT DETAILS SEE IS
NOT PROPERLY ENFORCING STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW AND ALLOWING
FACILITIES THAT HAVE NUMEROUS
VIOLATIONS OF STATE LAW.
AND REGULATIONS OR HAVE AN
EXPRED PERMIT TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE.
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY IS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LENGTH OF
TIME THAT IT TAKES DE TSC TO
PROCESS A PERMIT WITH PROCESSING
A PERMIT EXTENDING YEARS --
AT TIMES BEYOND THE EXPIRATION
DATE OF THE PERMIT.
THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH BOTH THE
BUDGET AND POLICY PROCESS HAS
MADE MANY ATTEMPTS TO REFORM
THIS DEPARTMENT AND REGAIN
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE AND
UNFORTUNATELY EACH OF THESE
ATTEMPTS WERE EITHER FORWARDED
OR MADE AND SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
THIS IS AN INDICATION THAT THE
PROBLEMS AFFLICTING THE
DEPARTMENT ARE FAR REACHING AND
SYSTEMIC.
DTS SEES CURRENT LEVEL OF
SERVICE IT IS EVIDENCED BY THEIR
SUBSTANTIAL HABIT HAZARDOUS
WASTE PERMIT BACKLOG.
HOWEVER BASED ON SOME OF THE
BUDGET ACTIONS LAST YEAR I FEAR
THAT DTS SEES FISCAL HEALTH HAS
DETERIORATED DETERIORATED
FURTHER TO A POINT WHERE CAN NO
LONGER SUSTAIN ITS FUNCTIONS.
EVEN AT CURRENT LEVELS IN ORDER
TO MAINTAIN FISCAL SOLVENCY AND
BOTH OF THEIR MAIN ACCOUNTS.
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FUNDED CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD NORMALLY
BE FUNDED OUT OF THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT OR
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT.
INSTEAD --
FUNDED WITH THEY WERE FUNDED
WITH THE LEAD ACID BATTERY FUND --
THIS -- TO
EMPLOYER DOUBLE METAPHOR --
PUTS US IN A POSITION WHERE
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL AND
FURTHER KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD -- IT
IS IT'S A DOUBLE METAPHOR.
YOU FOR CALLING ME ON THAT.
THE BUT IN POINT OF FACT THIS IS
REALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
WAITING TO RESOLVE THESE ISSUES
WOULD FURTHER JEOPARDIZE DTS
SEES ABILITY TO ME THAT'S
REGULATORY MANDATE --
THEIR ROLE IN PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC AND THE ENVIRONMENT IS
SIMPLY TOO IMPORTANT TO WAIT
FURTHER.
AND I HOPE THAT THIS HEARING
WILL BEGIN REFORM AND FIX THE
STATE'S MANAGEMENT OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE ONCE AND FOR ALL.
OF THIS IS A NEW ADMINISTRATION
AND A CHANCE TO MAKE PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HE
ENVIRONMENT A PRIORITY BY
FOCUSING OUR EFFORTS TO REFORM
THE STATE'S MANAGEMENT OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE --
SHOULD BE AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
MY CULTURES TO SAY A FEW WORDS
DUCT WORK.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM.
BOMB I THINK CHAIR BLOOM --
SUMMARIZED OF THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE IT'S EVIDENT TO ME AS WELL
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH
RESOURCES IN THAT WE DO HAVE A
NEW ADMINISTRATION AND WE'RE
HOPING TO WORK TOGETHER --
TO IMPROVE MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS
I HOPE --
GET THE ACT.
ADVOCATE RESOURCES --
TO FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO ACHIEVE
ITS VERY IMPORTANT MANDATES --
I WANTED --
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS YOU'RE HERE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
REBEKAH BAUER CON DEVON MATHIS --
ELOISE GOMEZ REYES JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA AND VINCE FONG --
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
SELDOM GET HEARING WITH THIS
MANY MEMBERS HAD AT AND I THINK
THAT SHOWS THE IMPORTANCE AND
SERIOUSNESS WITH WHICH WE TAKE
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR SENATOR ALAN.
A GOOD MORNING I WANT TO THANK
CHAIR BLOOM FOR INVITING MY
COMMITTEE JOINED THIS HEARING
THE DEPARTMENT THE THE
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY COMMITTEE --
IT'S CLEAR TO ALL OF US THAT THE
TSC HAS A CRITICAL --
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT MISSING
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
FROM TOXIC HARM AND JUST LIKE MY
COLLEAGUES I AM VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT --
SOME OF THE CONTINUE
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
FISCAL ISSUES THATWE'VE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT.
HOW THE DEPARTMENT?
OF THE STAFF ANNOUNCES THIRD OF
FOLKS MAY HAVE A NOTES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S LARGE.
AND GROWING REVENUE SHORTFALL
COULD FURTHER IMPEDE THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO CARRY
OUT ITS CORE MISSION AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY STAFF ALSO TALKS ABOUT HOW.
THERE ARE SEVERAL REASON
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS --
THAT HAVE BEEN PUSHED FORWARD TO
IMPROVE DGSE BUT AS WE KNOW
THEY'VE BEEN VETOED --
AND THEN THEY WERE USUALLY
VETOED CITING THE FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS AT THE DEPARTMENT
[inaudible]
SO.
LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON
AND WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM
OUR NEW SECRETARY OR ACTING
DIRECTOR ABOUT WHAT'S BEING DONE
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES MOVING
FORWARD --
ALSO LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM SOME OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS ENFORCEMENT AND
PERMITTING ISSUES A SOME OF OUR
HOUSE HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITY
SO THERE'S A LOT. TO UNPACK HERE
I'M VERYPLEASED THAT DIED CHAIR
BLOOM HAS AS AS REALLY TAKEN A
LEADERSHIP ROLE ON THIS ISSUE
AND LIKE TO TURN TO MY MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE.
THANK YOU --
DID YOU SEE FINANCES ARE KEY FOR
IT. TO PERFORM ITS CORE FUNCTION
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I'VE COVERED THESE ISSUES AS
BOTH THE POLISH FROM FOR BOTH
THE POLICY IN THE FISCAL A STAMP
POINTS IS MY ROLE HERE IS CHAIR
OF A BUDGET SUB TO IN THE SENATE --
FOR RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY BUT ALSO AS A FORMER
CHAIR OF ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
IN THE IN.
THE STM.
THE COMMON THREAD THAT I'VE SEEN
IN THE PAST YEARS AND THIS IS --
THREE A IS SET FORTH IN THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL NUMBER
STAKEHOLDERS IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT WE WE NEED
TO GET THE DEPARTMENTS FINANCES
AND PROGRAMS IN ORDER.
BUT I WOULD CAUTION PEOPLE ABOUT
THIS RUSH TO THE GATE TO
GUILLOTINE.
YOU KNOW THE CORE CHOMP OF OF
DTS SEE IS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY IT'S NOT BEING A DEBT
COLLECTOR IS NOT SENDING OUT
BILLS IT'S NOT SENDING OUT.
YOU KNOW REDUCING THEIR ACCOUNTS
PAYABLE YOU CAN BE AN EXCELLENT
DOCTOR.
INSTILL NOT COLLECT YOUR BILLS
AND MAYBE NOT SAID NOT YOUR
CHOP
GETTING THE JOB DONE.
WE WE'RE WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE BUDGETARY THE
ACCOUNTS OF THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACT IN THE TOXICS CUPS
AND SUBSTANCE CONTROL ACT.
THESE -- WE
FALL IN LOVE WITH SPECIAL FUNDS
BECAUSE WE THINK THESE MONIES
ARE GOING TO BE USED TO FUND
EVERYTHING AND WE FOUND OUT ITS
ARE IN THE REVIEW AND IN THE
YEAR OF HEARINGS THAT WE HAD ON
THE HIGH EFFICIENCIES BECAUSE I
CAN'T DO THAT JOB BECAUSE I'M
BEING.
PAID THAT IT THAT --
THE TOXIC.
SUBSTANCE CONTROL ACT AND I'M
AND THIS WOULD BE ANOTHER AREA
SO WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
FINANCIALLY HOW THIS MOVE THAT
OUT SO PEOPLE CAN PERFORM BETTER
IN THEIR ENTIRE JOB.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE SEEMS TO BE
A LOT OF DISCUSSION INVESTMENTS
WITHOUT QUESTIONABLE
CORRESPONDING IMPROVEMENT FUND
FROM EVERYBODY'S PART YOU KNOW
IT'S ONE THING IS THE I. R. I.
R. P. COMES OUT WITH THEIR
QUARTERLY RECOMMENDATIONS HAVE
ONE OFF BILLS TO COME IN ON ONE
LITTLE RECOMMENDATION.
AND NOT SIT BACK AND LOOK AT THE
WHOLE POLICY AFTER REPORT CAME
OUT LAST JANUARY SO WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THAT REPORT AND SAY WHAT
WE DOING.
I WILL REPORT THAT THE STATUTE
WE ARE ON IN THE PROCESS QUIETLY
OF HAVING THE STATUTE.
RE WRITTEN YOU KNOW SO THAT WHEN
TWO WERE ON THE SAME PAGE
WHETHER IT'S THE DEPARTMENT WITH
THIS ONE OF OUR LITTLE ONE OF
OUR COMMITTEES OR WHETHER IT'S
THE CONTROL THE THE PEOPLE WHO.
BUY BUY IT IT'S A PATCHWORK
BANDAIDS DUCT TAPE IT'S
INCREDIBLE SUGGEST KID.
ALL THE AREAS TO DEAL WITH.
AT LEAD ACID BATTERY IN ONE
CHAPTER SO EVERYBODY KNOWS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DOESN'T MAKE THE
HEADLINES FOR THE LA TIMES IN
THE CHRONICLE BUT IT'S GET THE
WORK IS GETTING DONE.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
ARE IMPERATIVE IN ORDER THAT WE
TOOK ADDRESSED THE PROBLEMS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE TO DTS HE'S
FINANCES ARE IN ORDER.
AND FUNCTIONING AS TO TAKE
CONSIDER IT'S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF ALL FOUR COMMITTEES
IN THE MEMBERS IT IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IS IN THE BEST INTERESTS IS OVER
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE AFFECTED.
AND THOSE.
WHO HAVE TO REGULATE WHO ARE
REGULATED BY THE TSA AND WITH
THAT LOOK FOR TO THE CURRENT?
THANK YOU WE ALSO WANT TO
WELCOME MY SENATORS SAID JONES
STONE AND MINING AND TO A WITH
ANY OTHER MEMBERS LIKE TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS AYE SOFTNESS
GOMEZ REYES HAD.
EARLIER.
THANK YOU FIRST I WANT.
TO THANK ALL THE COMMITTEES IN
ATTENDANCE TODAY IN THE
RESPECTIVE CHAIRS FOR SCHEDULING.
CRITICAL HEARING.
IT IS CLEAR THAT WE ARE HERE
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL HAS
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS.
THESE PROBLEMS HAVE EXISTED WILL
BE FOR SOME OF US WERE ELECTED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND A
PERSISTENT.
SINCE.
ALTHOUGH I DO NOT PRETEND THAT
THE CHALLENGES FACING THE
DEPARTMENT OR EASY TO FIX WHAT I
DO KNOW IS THAT THE CURRENT
FUNCTIONAL AND FISCAL STATUS.
OF DTS SEE IS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
FIXING WHAT SEEMS TO BE AN
ANNUAL AND REOCCURRING ISSUE
NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND I HOPE. FOR THE
NEW SOME ADMINISTRATION.
I BECAME INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE
WITH A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I
INTRODUCED AB.
TWO FORTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD HAVE
CHANGED THE TIMELINE FOR THE
SUBMISSION OF APPLICATIONS FOR
PERMITS RENEWAL.
THROUGH THE TSA TO ENSURE THEY
ARE PROCESSED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THEN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN VETOED
IT SAYING.
LET ME LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING TO ADDRESS THIS
CRITICAL PROBLEM.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
REINTRODUCE THIS MEASURE AND
ALTHOUGH HOPEFUL MY COLLEAGUES
AND I WERE NOT MET WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP NECESSARY. TO MOVE
THIS ISSUE FORWARD.
DTS THREE DOES NOT OPERATE IN
THE WAY THAT PROTECTS THE PUBLIC.
AND THIS LEAVES CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY IN DISADVANTAGED AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES EXPOSED
TO TOXIC SUBSTANCES THAT CAN
AFFECT THEIR LIVES FOREVER.
LIVES ARE AT STAKE AND OUR
URGENCY TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
MUST REFLECT THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
MEMBERS LIKE TO MAKE COMMENTS
THEN I I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE.
OUR FIRST AND ONLY PANEL --
TO A STEP FORWARD --
THEY WILL BE SECRETARY JARED
BLUMENFELD.
TO AND AMERICA'S WILLIAMS THE
ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL FRONT CHEST COULDN'T
AGREE THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
DTS.
AND SEAN MARTIN A PRINCIPAL
FISCAL POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
LA --
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU AND TO
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT TO THE SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO STAY FOR
THE ENTIRE HEARING --
HIGH AND SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE
MEMBERS IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OF
THE SECRETARY TO ASK --
PROBABLY AT THAT AT THE CLOSE.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU --
TO THE CHECK HAS BLOOM QUIRK Y.
KOWSKI ALAN AND TO ALL THE
MEMBERS -- I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT.
POINT -- AND
TIME FOR US TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHERE WE ARE AND UNDERSTAND
WHERE WE ARE AND I'M I'M REALLY.
THANKFUL FOR YOU CORAL CALLING
THIS HEARING TODAY --
I'M GOING TO PROCEED WITH
PROVIDE A VERY BRIEF
INTRODUCTION --
AND THEN YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM BOTH TALK TO MEREDITH
WILLIAMS AND FRANCESCA DEGREE IS
THAT --
CHIEF DEPUTY IN SOME DETAIL
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE ON THE BUDGET.
THE THE MAIN REASON THAT I
WANTED TO COME BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS TO HIGHLIGHT THREE BASIC
THINGS --
THE FAST IS THAT WE TAKE THE
FISCAL AND THE AND FISCAL HEALTH
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF DTS SEE
EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY.
SECONDLY THAT WE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE LAST
FEW MONTHS WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
ESTABLISHING.
A DTS THE LEDGE OF THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MANY YEARS HAS
RESULTED IN BOTH FINANCIAL
CLARITY.
AND ACCURACY AND FINALLY THE AS
THE SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIANS
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU ANTI TSC EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. TO ENSURE THAT WE GIVE YOU
FINANCIAL DAY.
THAT WE PROVIDE YOU WITH A PLAN
ON HOW WILL RECONCILE.
RECONCILE REVENUES --
A STABLE AND APPROPRIATE FUND
BALANCE AND EXPENDITURES.
AT THE END OF THIS EXERCISE IT
LIKELY THAT STRUCTURAL DEFICITS
WILL REMAIN.
AS YOU HAVE FROM FRANCESCA THE
DEFICITS ARE LARGELY A FACTOR OF
OUTDATED FEE STRUCTURES MARRIED
WITH CLEAN UP AND STAFFING COSTS
THAT HAVE OUTSTRIPPED REVENUE.
BEFORE WE CAN MAP DDS SEES PATH
TO FINANCIAL HEALTH WE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
EXPENDITURES THE EXPENDITURES
SIDE OF THE LEDGER.
THEY'LL BE EFFICIENCIES
RESULTING FROM MY WORKLOAD
MODELING THEY CAN REDUCE FUTURE
COSTS WHILE ALSO DOING A BETTER
JOB OF COST RECOVERY FROM
POLLUTERS.
AT THE SAME TIME.
COSTS INCLUDING A 10% COST YEAH --
AND OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
OF FEDERAL SUPERFUND SITES.
PLUS COSTING CATCHING CLEANING
EXISTING AND FUTURE OFTEN SITES
THOSE A SITES WHERE THERE'S NO
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES.
ALL SET TO INCREASE.
AS YOU HAD NONE OF THESE STEPS
WILL BE QUICK OR EASY BUT THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL.
ARMED WITH A CLEAR SENSE OF OUR
FINANCIAL FUTURE WE CAN TAKE THE
NEXT STEPS TO REBUILD TRUST IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE SAT.
THE COMMUNITIES THAT IN MANY
CASES FEEL LEFT BEHIND DI DI TSC.
I COMMITTED TO MAKING TO HELPING
DGSE MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE LAW.
AND IN FULL VIEW OF THE PUBLIC.
ONCE WE HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION
AND THE INPUT NEEDED TO MAKE A
DECISION I AM COMMITTED. TO
HELPING MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
COME QUICKLY.
APARTMENTS NEED TO BE WRITTEN IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THEY CAN BE
ENFORCED.
AND OUR ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TO BE
BOTH STRONG AND FAST.
HELLO FOR TO WORKING WITH EACH
OF YOU WITH THE PUBLIC HOUSE
STUFF AND THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY TO RETAIN THIS
IMPORTANT AGENCY BACK TO HEALTH.
I BE PLEASED ON TO ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE --
AND IN CLOSING I'D SAY THAT IN
THE UNITED STATES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY WIDE WHERE I
WAS THE REGIONAL ADMINISTRATOR.
FOR SEVEN YEARS I OVERSAW THE
SUPERFUND PROGRAM --
THAT SUPERFUND PROGRAM HAS A
HUNDRED PLUS SITES IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT WAS THE ROBUST PROGRAM
IT WAS WELL RUN --
THAT CASE MANAGES AND THAT DEBT
COLLECTING GOT THE BILLS PAID ON
TIME.
ARE ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS WERE
DONE ON TIME SO I'M FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT IT TAKES AND WHAT IT
LOOKS LIKE. TO HAVE AN EFFECTIVE
AND WELL RUNNING ORGANIZATION
THAT CLEANS UP HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITES AND I I JUST WANNA THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MANY OF YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS A
LONG TIME.
AND THE PROGRESS HASN'T BEEN
SUFFICIENT.
AND OUR GOAL IS TO WORK TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY AND TO SAY WHEN
WE HAVE PROBLEMS THE THE LAST
THING WE'RE GOING TO DO IS BE
DEFENSIVE ON HIGH DOUBLE IF WE
HAVE ISSUES WE'RE GONNA LET YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
AND WE GET A WET.
PIECE BY PIECE TO SELL THEM --
I THINK THAT THE KEY THERE IS A
LOT OF EXPECTATION --
FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS FROM THE
REGULATED COMMUNITY FROM ALL OF
USE THAT WE GET THIS RIGHT AND
I'M COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE ALL
THAT WE DO EXACTLY THAT --
SO WITH THAT I'M I'M HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR
FRANKNESS ON THIS ISSUE ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS DOCTOR QUIRK --
CONGRATULATIONS AND CONDOLENCES.
THE TSC IS GOING TO REQUIRE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MANAGEMENT
SKILL AND EXPERTISE AND I'M
HOPING YOU WILL --
DECIDE ON A ON A THE DIRECTOR OF
THAT AREA SOON.
SHOW IT.
THE PROBLEM ONE OF THE MAIN
PROBLEMS IS TIMELINESS WHETHER
IT'S ON PERMITTING HAZARDOUS
WASTE SITES CLEAN UP.
OR IN THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
PROGRAM THAT WE DISCUSSED A
LITTLE WHILE AGO.
AND WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
VERY WELL WHAT IT IS THAT
PREVENTS US FROM BEING TIMELY.
IT -- IT'S
LIKELY THAT RESOURCES IS SOME OF
THE PROBLEM BUT PROBABLY NOT ALL
OF IT AND WE JUST NEED TO HEAR
FROM YOU.
AND FROM THE DIRECTOR OF DTS SEE
WHEN THAT APPOINTMENT IS MADE.
WHAT ALL THE ROAD BLOCKS ARE
WHAT IS KEEPING THINGS FROM
HAPPENING MORE QUICKLY AND TO
WHAT EXTENT?
OF PERHAPS WE NEED TO CHANGE THE
REGULATION WHO WORK UNDER OR GET
YOU MORE RESOURCES --
I DON'T EXPECT YOU TO HAVE ANY
OF THOSE HAVING BEEN IN CHARGE
FOR ABOUT TWO WEEKS --
BUT I'M HOPING YOU WILL GET
THOSE TO US IN IN IN.
AS SOON AS YOU CAN.
I CAN PROVIDE SOME KIND OF
EXPLANATION OF I THINK.
WHAT'S ENTAILED I MEAN.
SO FOR INSTANCE WITH OFTEN SITES
IN CALIFORNIA IS NINE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED SITES THAT HAVE
KNOWS --
RESPONSIBLE PARTY --
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN CHARACTERIZED
EFFECTIVELY --
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
TOXIC IMPACT IS ON COMMUNITY
SAYS.
REALLY IT'S THINKING ABOUT
SYSTEMS --
SYSTEMS THAT WORKS HAS HAD A WE
CHARACTERIZE A SITE IN TIME TO
TOXICITY IN TIMES OF HUMAN
HEALTH EXPOSURES IMPOSSIBLE HE'S.
HAD WE DO THAT HOW DO WE THEN
MAKE SURE ALL THAT THAT
CHARACTERIZATION IS
SCIENTIFICALLY RIGOROUS.
AND THEN DO WE HAVE THE
CONTRACTS THE PEOPLE IN PLACE TO
DO THE CLEAN UPS IN A TIMELY WAY
WHERE WE HAVE TIME LINES THAT.
OFF.
VETTED FAST BE FULL AT I MEAN
THE MOST FRUSTRATING THING FOR
ANY COMMUNITY MEMBER.
IS OVER PROMISING AND UNDER
DELIVERING IT'S JUST
UNACCEPTABLE WE NEED TO HAVE
WHEN WE TELL SOMEONE THIS IS
WHAT IS GOING TO BE CLEANED OUT
AND THIS IS HOW MUCH IT'S GOING
TO COST.
NEEDS TO BEAR VERY CLOSE REAL
RESEMBLANCE BETWEEN THOSE TWO
THINGS -- IN
TIMES OF LEADERSHIP --
THE THE THREE OF US SPEND A LOT
OF TIME EACH DAY ON THIS WILL
ALL INVESTED IN THE MANAGEMENT --
AND ALL THOSE MEREDITH --
DOCTOR WILLIAMS IS ACTING I'M
FULLY IMPAIRING HAD TO TAKE THE
ACTIONS SHE NEEDS --
EVERY DAY WE COUNT WICKS --
AT THE SAME TIME --
JUST TO BE VERY FRANK I'M WITH
YOU I I SPEND A LOT OF I SPENT
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX YEARS IN
THIS SPACE DURING THIS WHACK --
WE NEED TO GET.
THE TIAS SEE TO A POINT OF
HEALTH BEFORE WE CAN GET SOMEONE
WHO WOULD WANT TO TAKE THE JOB
THAT WE WOULD WANT --
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW.
WHEN I'VE SCANNED THE PEOPLE
THAT I KNOW I'M YOU KNOW THAT
LIKE IT'S A IN A CRISIS POINTS
THAT WE NEED TO GET IT BACK TO A
TO A MODICUM OF HEALTH WITH
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT AND AND
FAST AND FOREMOST AS WORK IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE?
AS YOU HIT DOING INDEPENDENT OLD
AT TO GET THE NUMBERS STRAIGHT
WAVY IF WE CAN'T TELL YOU IF THE
NUMBERS WE GIVE YOU ON
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT CHANGE.
WE LOSE ALL YOUR CONFIDENCE WE
LOSE THE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
RELEASE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS CONFIDENT SO.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE SO GRATEFUL
FOR THIS HEARING TODAY BECAUSE
WE NEED YOU TO BE WITH US IN
LOCK STEP TO SAY THESE NUMBERS.
YOU CAN TRUST AND THIS IS WHY
AND TO SHOW YOU THE BACKGROUND
THE STUFF WHAT THAT WENT INTO
THOSE NUMBERS SO --
FISCAL HEALTH IS NUMBER ONE THE
SECOND REALLY IS.
EXPENDITURES WHEN I LOOK AT WHAT
WAS SPENDING IN THE DIFFERENT
SPECIAL ACCOUNTS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE ALL --
THAT.
THAT'S A LINED WITH STATUE WITH
THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITY THAT
THERE IS AN WHAT THAT AND THAT
THE WHAT WE DOING --
FRANKLY AT HIS TO SOME
PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT PLANTHAT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING THE
WORK.
REALIZE THAT THEY NEED TO STEP
UP ALL STEP OUT --
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
LACK THAT THAT WE JUST HAVE.
TO WE HAVE TO REALIZE THE
COMMUNITIES FACING THIS BUTTON --
FEEL THAT BUTTON DAY IN DAY OUT.
AND YOU KNOW CLEANUPS THAT TAKE
A LONG TIME YOU KNOW AS THE
STATEMENT WITH JUSTICE --
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED AND AND MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES FEEL THAT SO.
WE WILL HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENT
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON THE
AUTHORITIES WE CURRENTLY HAVE
DEAL POINT SENATE --
I DON'T KNOW IF WE NEED NEW WITH
ALREADY I WANT TO MAKE CAU
EXERCISING A CURRENT AUTHORITY
EFFECTIVELY BEFORE WE ASK THE
NEW ONES.
AND I WANTED TO ALSO INTRODUCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BRIAN DOLLY WHO JUST CAME IN.
AND SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT RESPONSE
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI.
ONYOUR THIRD PRONG AND THE
COMMITMENT TO DEVELOP A PLAN CAN
YOU GIVE US A TIME LINE ON THAT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE THREE OF
YOU CAN?
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHT RIGHT NOW AS
HOW LONG IT'S GOING.
TO TAKE TO DEVELOP THAT.
THAN TIME TO FISCAL HEALTH
YOU'LL HEAR FROM BOTH MEREDITH
IN FRENCH AS A KIND OF WHERE
WE'RE AT WHERE WE'RE GOING I'M.
WE'VE MADE SOME KEY HIGHER AS
SAID PRINCE SINCE WE'VE NEVER
HAD A CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER --
EXCEPT FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME --
WE JUST APPOINTED A CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER --
I THINK JUSTICE IS A VERY
GENERAL COMING WITHIN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT BUT
THERE'S OFTEN A PREFERENCE ON
JUST GETTING THE WORK DONE AS
OPPOSED TO HOW THE WORK GETS
DONE.
AND UNLESS WE HAVE THE FINANCIAL
UNDERPINNINGS THE ADMINISTRATIVE.
UNDERPINNINGS TO SUPPORT THE WAY
OVERSIGHT ALL LEADING CONTRACTS
TO MAKE SURE THE COMPANIES ARE
DOING WHAT WE WANT.
I'M PAYING YOU KNOW THE WAGES
NECESSARY ALL THOSE THINGS --
THAT WAS SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
FOCUSING ON I THINK --
FRENCH AS HE CAN GIVE YOU A THAT
A STATEMENT ON THE LIKE WHEN SHE
THINKS HE CAN GET THAT BACK WE
GETTING THAT QUICKER THAN I
THOUGHT --
ON TIME TO FISCAL HEALTH IN
TERMS OF WORKLOAD MODELS --
AND UNDERSTANDING WITH CLARITY
WHAT IT IS THAT I STOPPED DO AND
HOW THAT RELATES TO THESE FUNDS --
THAT THAT WILL BE PROBABLY FOUR
TO SIX MONTHS BEFORE WE CAN HAVE
A CLEAR SENSE OF HOW ALL THOSE
THINGS COME TOGETHER POT.
WITHIN OUR GOAL IS IS WITHIN A
YEAR.
IS TACK TO HAVE FISCAL HEALTH --
TO AND WE WILL WE MAY NOT BE
HEALTHY IN TIMES OF DAY HEY MAY
STILL BE DEFICITS BUT WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE SOURCE OF
THOSE DEFICITS ARE WALK
ADDITIONAL REVENUE WOULD DO IN
TIMES OF CLEAN UP --
JUST BY WAY OF EXAMPLE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL --
MY THE JURISDICTION THAT I
HELPED OVERSEE HAVE IS THE
ADMINISTRATOR OF REGION NINETY
PA OVERSAW ARIZONA NEVADA HAWAII
CALIFORNIA AND THE PACIFIC
ISLANDS AND CALIFORNIA HAD THE
SMALLEST OFTEN CLEAN UP FRONT OF
ALL THOSE STATES --
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF
SCALE --
NEVADA'S CLEANUP OFTEN CLEANUP
FUND WAS LODGED IN CALIFORNIA SO
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE WAY WE
DESIGN --
AND PRIORITIZE SITES THAT HAVE
NO RESPONSIBLE PARTY THAT'S AN
ISSUE -- AT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL
FIND WAS EIGHT TAX --
AND THAT TAX --
EVENTUALLY BECAME PART OF THE
GENERAL FUND SO THERE IS NO
LONGER A SUPERFUND TAX --
ALL THE EPA CLEAN UPS --
IS PAID FULL FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GENERAL FUND --
AND IF YOU WANT TO DO THIS WHAT
WELL AND YOU DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK AND HAVE TO CLEAN UP AGAIN
WHICH IS THE COMMENT WHEN I WAS
MEETING WITH COMMUNITIES WHY
DOES IT TAKE SO LONG WHY DO WE
NEED THE SCIENCE TO BE SO
RIGOROUS.
IT'S BECAUSE HE'S A VERY NASTY
TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT SYSTEM
BIOACCUMULATE.
FULL DECADES IF NOT CENTURIES
AND IF WE DON'T CLEAN THEM UP
PROPERLY WILL HAVE TO GO BACK
AND DO IT LATER.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THE MONEY TO SAY WHEN IT'S CLEAN.
EVERYONE TRUSTS THAT CONCERT AT
THE MOMENT THAT.
THE JURY I THINK IS STILL OUT ON
SOME OF DDS THESE PROJECTS --
LIKE I GUESS MY POINT THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND I GUESS MY FOLLOW
UP IS THAT WE KNOW THESE
FEDERALS SUPERFUND SITES ARE
GOING TO BECOME OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND AND SO YOU
WERE YOU WERE PROBABLY.
IN THE BEST POSITION LEAST KNOW
WHERE ARE A THAT THEY EXIST.
MORE COULD HAVE WHICH SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES EVEN IF
WE CAME UP WITH THAT THAT WHAT'S
WHAT THE A PLAN HERE AND THERE
WAS SOME GENERAL FUND YOU COULD
HAVE TO MAKE SOME.
REALLY DIFFICULT DECISIONS I
MEAN I'M HE PERCENT CLEANED UP
YOU GOTTEN OVER NINE THOUSAND
SITES THAT WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
THE TAXI THE OF THOSE IN AND IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE BODIES AND
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS YOU COULD
HAVE TO SAY.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS WORKS
BUT YOU SAY WE'RE GONNA STOP
THIS CLEAN UP WHICH GETS A WHOLE
GROUP OF PEOPLE SCREAMING AT
PASSED THE PUBLIC HEARING BUT
THEN AT LEAST EVALUATE AND DO
THE ASSESSMENT OF OUR THESE NINE
THOUSAND SITES.
SUPER SERIOUS SERIOUS. NINE AND
AND WE DON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION MENTIONED YOU DON'T
HAVE THE INFORMATION AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE SCARY WHEN WE HAVE
THIS.
THIS GREAT WAVE OF NEW FEDERAL
SITES THAT ARE GOING TO BE.
DELIVER TO OUR DOORSTEP AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN GIVE US
SOME INSIGHT ON HOW YOU
PRIORITIZE THAT MASSIVE
CHALLENGE JUST TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THE SITES ARE SO THAT THE PUBLIC
IN.
THE LEGISLATURE IN IN THE
DEPARTMENT KNOW WHAT THE THE
COURSE WORK IS.
I I WOULD NEVER WANT TO STOP THE
CLEAN UP HALF WAY THROUGH I MEAN
ONCE WE COMMIT TO CLEANING
SOMETHING UP I THINK WE OWE IT
TO EVERYONE.
INCLUDING I'M SIDING WITH WITH
WITH YOU AND THE PUBLIC TO MAKE
SURE WE FINISH CLEANING IT UP IN
TERMS OF THE THE LARGER LIST OLD
LET ME DEAL WITH THE THE
SUPERFUND QUESTION FAST SO --
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PUTS
A SITE ON THE NATIONAL
PRIORITIES LIST WHICH IS THE
SUPERFUND LIST --
TO COMMITMENT TO MADE BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN A LETTER.
THAT THE GOVERNOR --
NOT THIS COMING UP THE PREVIOUS
GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE OF SIGNED
SENSE OF THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE ON GOING OUT
OF THE OF THE CLEANUP ITSELF --
AND THEN OFF TO TEN YEARS TO PAY
THE OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE --
SO THERE'S A TWO SEPARATE COSTS
IN THE PAST TEN YEARS WE HAVE A
10% CUT SHALL BE ASIAN AND THEN
IN THE OUT YEARS WE HAVE OF A
FULL OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT PROJECTED --
EXPENDITURES IN THAT CATEGORY
THEY ARE COMING TO GO UP
SIGNIFICANTLY AND WE HAVE A
LEGAL OBLIGATION TO PAY THOSE --
SO.
THE THESE ON ALL KIND OF
WISHLISTS THIS IS I HAVE TO WE
WE HAVE --
TO BECAUSE THEY CLEAN UP
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE OBLIGATED
OURSELVES TO IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
JUST.
AN EXAMPLE WOULD BE IRON
MOUNTAIN MINE --
WHICH IS ON THE SACRAMENTO RIVER
IT WAS DEPOSITING MORE THAN A
TON OF TOXIC MATERIALS INTO THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER EVERY DAY.
BEFORE THE CLEAN UP WAS DONE --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT ONE
OF THESE SITES COULD BE ONE OF
THE NINE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND THEY SPEND MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS CLEANING
UP THAT SIDE --
AND THE OPERATION A MAINTENANCE
THAT SIDE IS GOING TO BE IN THE
MILLIONS EVERY YEAR --
SAYS THAT JUST --
ONE I CAN GO DOWN THE LIST OF
THE HUNDRED AND TEN THAT WE HAVE
BACK EVERY COMMUNITY LIVES NEXT
A SUPERFUND SITE.
EVERY COMMUNITY THAT LIVES NEXT
TO A A STATE HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITE.
THEY NEED TO KNOW --
THAT WE'VE CHARACTERIZED AT
LEAST TO THE CAST THREE LEVEL.
IT'S MATT --
THREE ITS PARKOUR ETHYLENE IT'S
T. C. KIND OF WALK ON THE
CONTAMINANTS THAT WITH LOOKING
AT HOW WATER THE EXPOSURE
PATHWAYS IS IN THE GROUND WATER
IT'S VOLATILE ISING UP THROUGH
INTO THE AIR IN THE BUILDING --
WE HAVE A VERY FOR INSTANCE FOR
INSTANCE HAS MORE SUPERFUND
SITES IN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
SO THE SEMICONDUCTOR INDUSTRY --
HAD A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON GROUND WATER WHICH IS VERY
VERY LOW LYING SAYS THE THAT
CHEMICALS.
IN.
THE WATER VOLATILE EYES INTO THE
AD AND GO INTO THE BUILDINGS --
COLD VAPOR INTRUSION AND BEG
THEIR BUILDINGS ALL OVER SILICON
VALLEY THAT WHERE THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT --
ISSUE -- WE
WOULD JUST AT SANDERS IS AN AT
FIELD LEBAR TREE --
IN SIMI VALLEY.
THAT SHOULD BE A ONE OF THE ONLY
PLACES I MEAN THE UNITED STATES
WHERE THAT WAS A NUCLEAR
MELTDOWN --
THAT WAS MORE THAN A MILLION
GALLONS OF T. C. E. UM THAT WAS
PUT INTO THE SOIL THAT SO.
WE HAVE OUR WE'LL KNOW THIS WE
HAVE OUR WORK CUT OUT FOR US --
THE EXPENSE I I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN
ANY OF US CAN ANTICIPATE
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE LEGACY
THAT WE HAVE --
FROM ALL THESE INDUSTRIES --
THAT TOOK PLACE BEING OF MAINLY
FROM THE NINETEEN FIFTIES TO THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES IN CALIFORNIA
AND SOME OF THEM DON'T HAVE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES.
SAYS CHARACTERIZATION IS NUMBER
ONE AND THEN A PLAN.
WELL WE ALL WERE IN AGREEMENT I
DON'T TO BE IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
THAN ANYONE ELSE I WANT EVERYONE
TO SAY THIS IS THE LAST THIS
MAKES SENSE WE'VE LOOKED AT IT
WE DONE OUR DUE DILIGENCE.
AND WE TRY TO PRIORITIZE IT --
SENATOR BASED ON THOSE RISK
FACTORS UNKNOWN AND AND NOT
MAKING UP OUR OWN.
USING USING SCIENCE IT IS
ALREADY OUT OF THAT --
AND AND STICKING TO THAT MISSION
UNTIL WE CLEAN IT UP.
THANK YOU SOBRE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION BUT A COMMENT AS YOU'RE
GOING TO BE LEAVING BUT I HAVE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS FOR
COLLEAGUES LEADER --
WE PASSED AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE WHICH CREATED THE BATTERY
FEE -- AND
WE MADE A PROMISE HERE AND WITH
A BIPARTISAN PROMISE OF THE
LEGISLATURE NUMBERS WORK ON THAT
TO THE COMMUNITY --
HOW THOSE FUNDS FOR GOING TO BE
USED WE HAVE NOW SEEN MULTIPLE
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS WHERE IT'S
BEING USED AS BUDGET GIMMICKS?
ALONG SO IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET.
WE TOOK --
ONE POINT TWO MILLION TO REPAY
THE TIRE BY LOAN.
WE APPROPRIATE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION TO THE H. W. CA FUNDS WE
APPROPRIATED TEN MILLION TO
REPAY.
A LOAN A GENERAL FUND LOAN WE
SAW THAT AGAIN IN IN THIS BUDGET
AND WHILE THERE WAS A VICTORY
LAP THAT WAS DONE WHEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS RELEASED
IN JERRY.
THAT EX THAT WAS GETTING AN
INFORMATIONAL FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS RATING THAT FINE WAS
AGAIN FOR OTHER THINGS.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT AS WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
WE CREATED A FINE WITH THE
PROMISE TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THERE'S LIKE A TRUST AND AS LONG
AS THAT FUND IS BEING SEEN IN
OTHER WAYS WERE COSTLY VIOLATING
THAT TRUST AND THE COMMUNITY OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE FRUSTRATED
AND UPSET WITH THE PROCESS TO
CLEAN UP AND I TELL --
THIS IS.
YOU KNOW WE ARE LEARNING HAVE
PATIENCE ON THE GROUND AND THEN
THEY SAID OKAY MAYBE ONLY TO DO
THAT BUT WHY DO YOU KEEPING THIS
FIND -- WHEN
WE FINALLY FIGURED OUT HOW TO DO
IT RIGHT EVER GONNA HAVE ALL THE
MONEY WE NEEDING YES TO CLEAN
THEM HAS BEEN SLOW OR SPENDING
THE MONEY HAS BEEN SO AND I
WOULD LIKE IT TO BE?
BUT IN VERY WE KEEP SAYING WE'RE
GETTING BETTER AND BETTER AT IT
EVERY DAY SO THIS'LL --
YOU KNOW GET PAST AND WILL BE
USING THAT MONEY FASTER IS THAT
MONEY GOING TO BE THERE.
ON AND SUCH AS WANT TO MAKE SURE
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS WERE
NOT RATING OF FUND WERE NOT
BREAKING THAT PROMISE THAT THAT
PROMISE THAT US AS LEGISLATORS
MADE. TO EACH OTHER AND TO THE
CONSTITUENCIES COMMUNITIES --
IT WE HAVE A LOAN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED TO BE
PAYING THAT LOW ENOUGH NOT TO
THE STATE OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX MILLION DOLLAR WHY
AREN'T WE DOING THAT AGAIN WHEN
THE CLEANUP IS DONE.
WE HAVE AT LEAST TEN THOUSAND
HOMES FROM BACKSIDE. TO CLEAN UP
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE --
WE TOOK MONEY FOR PARKWAYS AND
WE SAID OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION FOR FOR
THE PARK WAYS TO CLEAN UP.
FROM THE LEAD ACID BATTERY FUND --
BUT THEN WE TOOK AN ADDITIONAL
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS AND SO
WE TOOK THIS VICTORY LAP FOR THE
PARKWAYS.
BUT THE ONLY RATED IT WOULD
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS AS A LIST
THAT PLAYING THESE GAMES WITH
EACH OTHER AND WITH THE
CONSTITUENCIES AND AND THE
BUDGET.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR THAT --
I'M NOT WILLING TO TAKE THAT
VICTORY LAP BUT THE GOVERNOR ON
THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS AND I
THINK WE NEED TO REVISIT THAT.
OF HOW WE'RE USING THESE DOLLARS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AT THIS
POINT CENTER STONE THANK YOU
FIRST OF ALL --
SECRETARY BLOOM FELT WELCOME TO
THE ARENA WHERE WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE YEAR ROUND VERY IMPRESSED
WITH THEIR CREDENTIALS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU --
THE TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL
ACCOUNT GENERATES --
REVENUE FROM TAXES IS ASSESSED
ON ALL BUSINESSES BASED ON THE
ASSUMPTION THAT ALL BUSINESSES
CREATE ENVIRONMENTAL WASTE.
WHICH WE KNOW ISNOT TRUE BUT
THAT'S THE THE NATURE OF THE OF
THE REVENUE STREAMS.
AND MOST THESE TAX REVENUES OR
USE -- FOR
POST CLEAN UP AND AND COST OF
SUPERS FUNDS SITES.
BUT OF THERE'S A QUESTIONS BASED
ON WHAT I HEARD FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN WHAT I'VE OBSERVED
IS THAT THE DEPARTMENT --
IS IN DISARRAY --
INABILITY TO CLEAR PERMIT BLOW
SHARKS FINAL SIR FISCAL
UNCERTAINTY.
ON FUND RESERVES --
AND I SHIP SAME CONCERNS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA --
ALSO SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS
WITH SENATOR --
WHITE KASKI ABOUT.
PRIORITIZING --
THROUGH QUICK QUALITATIVE
ANALYSIS THE THE NATURE OF THE
SEVERITY OF THE TOXIC SITES.
THAT EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OUR CONCERNS ABOUT THE AGENCIES
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
LONG TERM STABILITY OF THE DTS
SEE -- MY
CONCERN IS A WE HAVE A VERY
FRAGILE ECONOMY WITH OUR
BUSINESSES THAT ARE.
OVERTAXED AND STRESSED --
THERE WAS A RECENT --
STUDY THE POLL WAS TAKEN SAID
53% OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
CONSIDERING LEAVING THE STATE
AND AND MANY OF THOSE ARE FOR
BUSINESS REGULATIONS AND TAX
REASONS.
SO -- IS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING ANY
GENERAL FUND UTILIZATION FOR
URGENT.
CLEANUP --
GIVEN THE STATE'S TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
PURPOSE AND IF THE DEPARTMENT IS
NOT OPERATING EFFICIENCY.
WHICH CREATES MORE MORE COSTS.
SHOULD WE NOT PENALIZE THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND ACCEPT
THE FACT THAT WERE RUNNING AN
EFFICIENT BASED ON OUR OWN
LEADERSHIP IN THE DEPARTMENT.
AND LET YOU SOME OF OUR GENERAL
FUND RESERVES TO TO FIX THE
PROBLEM INSTEAD OF GOING BACK TO
THE WELL.
OF THE BUSINESSES THAT --
SUSTAINER CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THE DAYS JUST GENERAL
COMMENTS --
AS IT RELATES TO THIS.
I'VE I THINK OUR GOAL TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE GET TO A PLACE
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW THESE
FEES AS A GENERATED --
AND IS TOO BAD M. MARY.
THE THE ENTITIES GENERATING A
LOT OF WAYS TO THE MORE YOU
GENERATE THE MORE TOXIC IT IS
THE MORE YOU PAY.
AS OPPOSED TO AT THE MOMENT THAT
ENTITIES THAT DON'T GENERATE IT
SEEMS AS FOR MIKE HAS THREE LOOK
ANY HAZARDOUS WASTE THE PAYING
IN. TO THE FUND SO I THINK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD DOT OUR GOAL IS IS
TO REALLY --
THE ANYWAY WE GET YOU KNOW A
HUNDRED YEARS FROM NOW PEOPLE
LOOK BACK AT TODAY.
DEAD MAN NUMBER ONE QUESTION IS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE WE NOT
PUTTING YOU TOXIC MATERIAL INTO
THE GROUND AND SO REDUCING THE
AMOUNT THAT WE GENERATE.
SHOULD BE OUT OUR NUMBER ONE
GOAL AND ONE OF THE WAYS OF
DOING THAT IS MAKING SURE ALL
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT PRODUCE THE
MOST WASTE PAID THE MOST AMOUNT
OF MONEY --
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WOULD
EVENTUALLY GET TRANSLATED INTO.
INTO SOME FEE SYSTEM BUT SADLY
THAT'S THE APPROACH I'M AND THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE ACCOUNT --
IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE TAKING.
A FEW BITES OF THE SAME PEOPLE
IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND IT IT DOES
DEFINITELY UP A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EFFICIENCY IN
THE WAY THAT WE DO THAT --
AVERAGE I WOULD SAY THAT --
TO ASSEMBLYMAN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GARCIA'S PINE --
I THINK IT'S BEEN REALLY HARD TO
DTS SEE TO STAND UP AND SAY.
THIS IS WHAT WE THINK THIS IS
WHY WE HAVE THESE THE ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
IN CRISIS MODE AND SO WE NEED TO
GET TO THE NEXT PLACE WHERE IT
CAN CLEARLY ARTICULATE THIS IS
WHAT OUR NEEDS ARE.
AND AND PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT AND TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND
AND TRUSTED.
AND IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT --
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT PARTICULAR
ACCOUNT --
BUT I CAN'T.
TO WHERE THERE'S AN AGENCY THAT
SAYS NO WE NEED THIS MONEY TO DO
THIS THING SLIGHTLY IN THE US
EPA CONTEXT --
WE WOULD FIGHT FOR THOSE BUDGET
LINES -- AND
PEOPLE REALLY UNDERSTOOD AND
CONGRESS MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE
SPOKE TO UNDERSTOOD THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUPER FUND
ALLOCATIONS AND WHERE THAT WENT
TO AND HOW IT SPED UP THE CLEAN
UP AND YOU KNOW THE THE THE
OTHER OBVIOUS.
QUESTION IS MORE MONEY SHOULD
LEAD TO SPEEDY OF MORE EFFECTIVE
CLEAN UPS AND SAID THAT THEY
NEED TO BE A CORRELATION BETWEEN
THOSE THINGS --
SO -- WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO --
I AM PRESENTLY.
OF THE BELIEF THAT MANAGEMENT IS
AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOOL --
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING
HOW WE'RE DOING AT HOW WE'RE
PAYING FOR IT AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK IN THE LAST YEAR'S
ABOUT STRUCTURAL CHANGES FOR ME.
LET'S WORK OUT HOW WE'RE DOING
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW DO IT.
AS WELL AS WE CAN AND THEN LOOK
AT THE STRUCTURAL ISSUES --
AND I AM ACCOUNTABLE TO THE USE
OF THE PUBLIC TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
GETTING THIS DONE AND IT'S A
PRIORITY FOR ME --
BECAUSE OF ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE DO IF YOUR IN A COMMUNITY
LIVING NEXT TO HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITY --
LED TO CIVILITY IT'S INTOLERABLE
AND YOU WANTED DEALT WITH AND
THAT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS
GOVERNMENT --
AND REBUILDING TRUST IS AT A
HUGE PRIORITY OF OF MINE.
MISTER SECRETARY DESERVE ONE
FINAL FOLLOW UP --
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO LOOK AT THE THE THE FUNDING
AND THE NEXUS --
TO RELEASING HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
THE FEES THAT ARE THAT ARE
GENERATED --
ANOTHER THING I HOPE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO ENTERTAIN AS THE THE
NEW SECRETARY IS --
EFFICIENCIES YOU'VE YOU
MENTIONED THAT A LITTLE BIT --
WE JUST YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR PROP --
ONE REVENUES IN PART OF THE PROP
ONE WAS TO FIND EFFICIENCIES A
CALTRANS ANOTHER TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND EFFICIENCIES WERE
FOUND SO I HOPE THAT YOU WILL BE.
EMBRACING TECHNOLOGY AND AND
MANAGEMENT STYLES THAT WILL.
SHOW TO OUR TAXPAYERS SAID YES
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUE THAT AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE SWORN TO PROTECT AS
WE TAKE THESE OFFICES AND WE
DEPEND ON YOU AND CERTAINLY THE
STAFF OF THE DEPARTMENT.
TO ENSURE THAT THE MONEY IS
SPENT WISELY S I I HOPE THAT
YOU'LL YOU'LL --
LEON SILICON VALLEY THAT.
YOU YOU MENTIONED IS A IS A
NIGHT AS FOR A LOT OF THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL --
TOXICITY --
BUT ALSO TAP THEIR TECHNOLOGY --
IN A WAY IN WHICH WE CAN RUN THE
DEPARTMENT MRE EFFICIENTLY
WHICH MEANS IT'S GOING TO BE RUN
LESS EXPENSIVELY.
REFRIGERATOR YOUR PRESENCE I'M A
BIG FAN OF LEAN. SIX SIGMA SO
THE WELL I MEAN AD TELLING
MISTER SECRETARY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR RESPONSE WE HAVE
THREE PEOPLE WAITING IN THE IN
THE QUEUE --
I I WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
ABOUT GIVEN THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
ONLY BEEN ON THE JOB FOR A
COUPLE WEEKS --
AND COMPLIMENT YOU ON THAT I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO THOSE WHO
ARE GOING TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ASK QUESTIONS --
THAT WE HAVE.
PEOPLE HERE WHO ARE IN THE
TRENCHES AND PROBABLY A LITTLE
BIT -- MORE
ABLE TO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE
VERY DETAILED --
QUESTIONS SO JUST BEAR THAT IN
MIND AS YOU PROCEED --
WE HAVE SENATOR STERN FOLLOWED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY AND FONG.
THANK YOU MISTER.
AND WELCOME MR SECRETARY.
HIGH YOU KNOW IT THE HE SEES
THIS WELL VERSED BECAUSE HE'S
DONE A JOB LIKE THIS BEFORE
RUNNING EPA REGION NINE WAS NO
SMALL TASK SO WE'RE HOPING YOU
BRING SOME OF THAT SAME TACKY
MEN AND DISCIPLINE.
TO THIS AGENCY AND ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN IT SO --
IT IS NOT EASY BUT I APPRECIATE
EVERYTHING I'VE HEARD THIS
MORNING AND THANKS ALREADY FOR
GETTING STARTED WE KNOW THAT --
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE SITES YOU IS
WERE MADE AND HAVEN'T REALLY
BEEN FOLLOWED THROUGH ON HIS
SANTA SUSANNA.
AS YOU SAID MILLION GALLONS A
TCP COMMITMENT SPEND TWENTY TEN
THANKS FOR VISITING THE SITE AND
ALSO FOR TRYING TO HOLD THE FEDS
ACCOUNTABLE SHOULD WANT TO GET
INTO THAT DYNAMIC A LITTLE BIT
WITH YOU HERE JUST.
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
COMPLICATED RELATIONSHIP WE'VE
GOT WITH.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHERE
THEY ARE OFTEN A RESPONSIBLE
PARTY -- IN
THIS CASE DEPARTMENT ENERGY AND
NASA WHO BUILT OUR ROCKETS THAT
SPILLED OUT ALL THAT T. C. E.
ALONG WITH BOEING FOR THEIR
CORPORATION PRIOR TO THAT.
WERE SOME OF THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES ALREADY IDENTIFIED WE
MADE COMMITMENTS IN.
TWENTY TEN LOOKS LIKE THE FEDS
ARE TRYING TO FALL BACK.
AND BREAK THEIR COMMITMENTS
RIGHT NOW THE DEPARTMENT ENERGY
PUT OUT A PRETTY WEAK NY BUT
NOW SIS.
WHICH I APPRECIATE THAT IDT.
SENT THAT LETTER BACK IN
DECEMBER SAYING THIS DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE YOU'RE MEETING YOUR
YOUR YOUR CONSENT ORDERS YOUR
YOUR CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS TO
CLEAN UP --
BUT HOW DO YOU SEE THINGS
PROCEEDING AT SANTA SUSANNA BOTH
FROM -- DTS
SEE ABOUT AND YOU KNOW WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO I THINK THE CLEANUP
TIMELINE WAS TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BACK IN TWENTY TEN AND IT'S
TWENTY NINETEEN AND WE HAVEN'T
EVEN GOT STARTED SO.
I DON'T EXPECT YOU HAVE A FULL
ANSWER RIGHT NOW AND I KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE.
YOU'RE STILL MIDWAY THROUGH YOUR
SEQUEL PROCESS AND YOUR
ENVIRONMENTAL ANNOUNCES
INCOMPLETE SO MAYBE YOU KNOW --
THE ACTING DIRECTOR ALSO COULD
COMMENT THEIR WAY AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BUT I JUST
WANTED AT A HIGH LEVEL --
YOU KNOW THE FEDS ARE ON THE
HOOK FOR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS A
COSTS AND THEY'RE TRYING TO GET
OUT OF IT COMPLETELY --
WE MEANWHILE HAVE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AND PRIVATE PARTIES
SO.
ANY JUST INITIAL --
TAKE ON WHAT CAN BE DONE.
SHAW I'M OUT OF A GIVE A VERY
INITIAL TAKE --
AND IT'S A COMPLETE MESS --
AND YOU KNOW THE LEVEL OF
TOXICITY THE HISTORY THAT IS
WHEN YOU'RE ON SITE IS JUST.
DEPRESSING I MEAN EVERYWHERE YOU
LOOK THERE WAS --
FLAGRANT VIOLATIONS OF EVEN WHAT
THEY KNEW BACK IN THE DAY --
ANOTHER CASE I WORK DONE IN MY
LAST JOB WAS URANIUM MINING ON
THE NAVAJO NATION --
THAT WAS FOR THE SAME EXACT
EFFORT TO BUILD --
WEAPONS FOR THE COLD WAR --
AND IT WAS IMPORTANT WHAT BUT IT
IT WITHOUT IT HAD A HUGE TOXIC
LEGACY SO IT'S HAND THIS IS ANNA --
JUST FOR THE THE OTHER MEN THAT
SAYS THEM THREE PARTY SAID NASA --
THE POT OF ENERGY AND BOEING.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AN AGREEMENT CALLED OLD ON
CONSENT.
WITH THE TO FEDERAL AGENCIES IN
THAT ORDER IS TO CLEAN UP THE
FACILITY TO BACKGROUND AND IT
WAS INKED.
BY STEPHEN TO THE NOBEL LAUREATE --
WHO'S THE HEAD OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY AT THE TIME AND NASA
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
AND AND I WAS --
AT EPA THAT TIME IT'S IT'S NOT.
IT DOESN'T GIVE DISCRETION TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THERE IS
NO THIS IS WHAT THEY LIKE TO DO
IT'S VERY CLEAR WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO --
IT'S LEGALLY COMPELLING DOCUMENT
THAT WE CAN GET COURTS TO HELP
IN FALSE --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
WANT TO PAY.
I'M AND IN MY EXPERIENCE IT
USEPA -- WE
WILL VERY UNPOPULAR BECAUSE WE
WOULD HOLD OTHER FEDERAL
AGENCIES ACCOUNTABLE --
WE NEED AS A STATE ACCOUNT SHOW
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES
TWO THINGS.
ONE DOES WHAT IT SAYS IT WAS
GONNA DO AND SECOND.
CASE FOR WHAT IT SAYS IS GOING --
TO BUT YOU SAID IT'S IT'S GOING
TO BE -- A
STRUGGLE BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT --
ISN'T PRIORITIZING THESE KIND OF
CLEAN UPS AND THEIR GOAL IS IF
YOU HAVE A LESS STRINGENT
CLEANUP STANDARDS.
AND THIS MAKES SENSE TO ALL OF
US YOU PAY LESS TO CLEAN IT UP.
SAID THERE'S A DIRECT
CORRELATION --
BETWEEN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY
PAY AND THE LEVEL OF CLEAN U WE
RECEIVE --
AND THEN BOEING --
AS ANOTHER PORTION OF THE SITE
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THEY
GET HIT TO THEIR OBLIGATIONS
WHICH ALSO LEGALLY BINDING WITH
US -- SAYS.
ALL THAT REQUIRES LEGAL --
GOAL THAT REQUIRE AS BE PEOPLE
KNOWING YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS
THE BOTTOM LINE THAT PEOPLE KNOW
THAT WE ARE IN IT WE ARE SERIOUS
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO WALK AWAY
FROM THE PROJECT AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO ALLOW OTHERS TO WALK
AWAY FROM THAT COMMITMENTS.
THAT'S HARD TO DO WHEN.
YOU KNOW T. SENATE --
SENATE DISTANCE COMMENTS --
WHERE IN DISARRAY WE HAVE BEEN
IN DISARRAY WE WORKING EVERY DAY
TO MAKE A DECISION TO MOVE THE
AGENCY BACK INTO HEALTH?
BACK INTO A PLACE WHERE RUNNING
PROPERLY --
BUT RETOOLING WORKING OUT THE
BUDGET IS AND HOLDING VERY LARGE
SOPHISTICATED POLLUTERS
ACCOUNTABLE IS REALLY DIFFICULT
SO WE NEED TO PUT SOME STUFF
BEHIND US WE NEED TO MOVE PAST
THAT ERA OF DISARRAY.
INTO A HERO ALL OF WE'VE GOT A
FEW ISSUES THAT WAY SOLVING
TOGETHER AT THIS IS WHAT THE
THIS IS HOW WE DOING THEM AT THE
SAME CLEAN IT UP --
WE MET WITH FAMILIES THAT LIVE
AROUND THE SITE --
THIS MIGRATION OFFSITE FROM THAT
FACILITY --
TO COMMUNITIES AND IT WAS REALLY --
EMOTIONALLY DEVASTATING.
YES MOMS TALKING ABOUT THE YOUNG
KIDS THAT HAVE CANCER --
AND YES IT DOES A VERY REAL AND
PERSONAL FACE TO ALL THESE SITES
AND WE WE KIND OF KNOW THAT AT
THE SAME TIME.
WE NEED TO BE RIGOROUS AND
DISCIPLINED AND DILIGENT IN OUR
APPROACH TO TO SOLVING AT THANKS.
THREE DOLLARS.
PAYMENT YOUR REAL QUICK --
SO YOU TALK ABOUT THE NINE
THOUSAND SITES THAT ARE --
I GUESS THE OR FROM SITES WE
COLUMN RIGHT.
WHERE THEY OUT IN THE PROCESS OF
THE BEEN?
CATEGORIZED OF THEIR TOXICITY
AND RATE AND THEN I'M ASSUMING A
LOT OF THESE OUR BROWN FIELDS IN
AREAS WHERE.
THEY DID KNOW THERE WAS A
PROBLEM.
I JUST WOULD LIKE THAT --
TO DOCTOR WILLIAMS CAN AM --
AND FOR TO HAVE TO GO IN A
SECOND BUT DOCTOR WILLIAMS AND A
HAT TESTIMONY CANNOT TO THAT
QUESTION --
I WOULD SAY THAT.
MORE THAN A THIRD OF THEM --
DRY CLEANERS --
SAYS [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
THE POPULAR ATHLETE THAT COMES
OUT OF DRY CLEAN AS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT SUPERFUND SITES --
IS ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
THINGS TO CLEAN UP --
GAS STATIONS AND OTHER THINGS
THAT BROWN FIELDS THAT CAN HAVE
BENEFICIAL ECONOMIC RE USE --
OBVIOUSLY A PRIORITY AND AND WE
WOULD FOCUS ON THAT IS THAT YOU
CAN TURN THEM AROUND CERTIFY
THAT THEY CLEAN AND MOVE ON BUT
LET'S HAVE MEREDITH IN A MINUTE
CAN CAN ADDRESS THAT SPECIFIC
QUESTION.
SECRETARY NEEDS TO LEAVE
EMINENTLY I THANK GOD I SEE
STAFF --
WAITING ANXIOUSLY A MISTER FONG.
BUT VERY BRIEF --
EDGE JUST ONE QUESTION --
COULD YOU HIGHLIGHT OR MAYBE
YOUR STAFF WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS DOING AS WHAT'S DOES THE
STRUCTURE TO LOOK LIKE IS THERE
AND REVIEW GOING ON COULD YOU
SHOULD SUCH AS A MIGHT ON THAT.
DEBT TO GREAT A GREAT QUESTION --
AND FRANCISCO WAS PREPARED TO
TALK ABOUT THAT AND AND WILL --
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS RIGHT
AND I I THINK OFTEN WE WERE
AFRAID OF MAKING A DECISION IN
ANY CONTEXT IN LIFE --
BECAUSE THESE A DIFFICULT
DECISIONS YOU KNOW REAP HAVING A
FACILITY THAT NO ONE LIKES AB.
YEAH DELUDE DEALING WITH
HAZARDOUS WASTE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IS IT'S TOUGH.
MY ASSUMPTION --
AT USEPA WE WERE SUED EVERY
OTHER DAY OF THE WEEK MY
ASSUMPTION IS SOMEONE'S GOING TO
SUE US SO LET'S JUST MAKE A
DECISION TO MOVE ON AND ALLOW
THAT PROCESS. TO MOVE FORWARD IF
THEY DON'T TO US WE'VE MADE A
TIMELY GOOD DECISION IF THEY DO
WE JUST ACCEPT THAT SOME PART OF
DOING BUSINESS WITH VERY
CONTROVERSIAL.
VERY COMPLEX SITES BUT I DON'T
WANT IT ON US BY ONCE WE HAVE
THE INFORMATION --
THE SCIENCE THE LAW.
WE NEED TO MOVE THESE THINGS
THROUGH MAKE THE DECISIONS MOVE
ONTO THE NEXT THING --
BECAUSE WE ARE BEING DONE ANY OF
IT IS THE REGULATED COMMUNITY
BEING.
WE ARE DEALING WITH THIS
RIDICULOUS LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY
WE ARE BECAUSE WE HAVE MORAL PAM
IT'S ENOUGH BACKLOG AND WE LOOK
LESS AND LESS.
PROFESSIONAL TO USE SO MY
COMMITMENT IS WILL MAKING
DECISIONS MOVING ON AND TALKING
MOVIE ON I HAVE TO GO BY I AS AS
PARTNERS ON THIS ALBUM.
I REALLY IF THERE ARE QUESTIONS
WITH ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO TO
ENGAGE IN A DISCUSSION ON HOW
WITH THINKING ABOUT MOVING DE
DST TOWARDS HEALTH HOW.
YOU'LL THINKING IT CAN WORK --
AND DAY IN DAY OUT I'M ENGAGED --
I DON'T WANT TO BE MICROMANAGING
BUT AT THE SAME TIME AND I'M
GONNA BE DOING THIS EVERY DAY OF
EVERY WEEK TO WE SOLD IT OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
DOCTOR ARAMBULA CAN YOUR
QUESTION WAIT.
FOR YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME SPENT THIS
MORNING CAM TO LOOK FOR TING
AGAINST SAN --
SO WILL PROCEED NOW WITH THAT
TESTIMONY FROM MEREDITH WILLIAMS
SO FOLLOWED BY FRANCESCA NAY
GREEK AND SHAUN MARK.
THE MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE.
AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN HELPING
DSE ACHIEVE THE MISSION TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS AND AT
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE
ENVIRONMENT FROM CHEMICAL
ANOTHER HARM.
AT THE RECENT GREEN CHEMISTRY
HEARING WHICH MANY OF YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO ATTEND I HAD A CHANCE
TO SHARE.
WITH YOU SOME OF HOW THE
DEPARTMENT HAS IMPLEMENTED THOSE
REGULATIONS USING SCIENTIFIC
RIGOR.
TRANSPARENCY PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT.
SECOND SECRETARY BLUMENFELD HAS
ASKED ME TO HELP LEAD DGSE
DURING THIS TRANSITIONAL PERIOD.
AND APPLY THE SAME PRINCIPLES TO
THE REST OF THE DEPARTMENT.
WE'VE DISCUSSED THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES OF THE DTS HE FACES
AND ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. TO ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES.
THE DEPARTMENT'S CLEAN UP
PERMITTING AND ENFORCEMENT WORK
AND CONSUMER PRODUCTS SAFETY
EFFORTS.
VITAL TO THE STATE.
A QUICK LOOK AT OUR THREE
PROGRAM AREAS GIVES A SENSE OF
THE SCOPE OF OUR WORK.
MUCH WHICH IS NOT NEWS TO YOU --
SITE MITIGATION AND RESTORATION
PROGRAM IS ACTIVELY OVERSEEING
CLEAN UP OF LEAD PERK TRUCK
TRICOLOR ETHYLENE HEXAVALENT
CHROME LET CYANIDE AND HOPE.
CHEMICALS.
MUCH OF THIS ACTIVITY IS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE TWENTY TO
PRIORITIZE SUPERFUND SITES
AROUND THE STATE.
OF THOSE.
TWELVE SITES ARE LOCATED IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AS DEFINED UNDER
CALIFORNIA CALLIN VIRUS SCREEN.
AS MENTIONED WE EXPECT THE
STATE'S OBLIGATIONS TO SUPPORT
SUPER SUPER FUN REMEDIATION AND
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE TO
TRIPLE.
OVER THE NEXT THREE FISCAL YEARS.
THE STATE'S CLEANUP EFFORTS NEED
TO BE TIMELY AND EFFECTIVE.
THEY NEED TO BE UNDERTAKEN BASED
ON CLEANUP STANDARDS THAT ARE
GROUNDED IN SOUND SCIENCE.
AND THEY NEED TO BE CONDUCTED
WITH MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT.
OF THE AFFECTED COMMUNITIES IN
THE PLANNING AND EXECUTION OF
OUR CLEANUPS.
HAZARDOUS WASTE PERMITTING AND
ENFORCEMENT.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA ENTITIES
GENERATED ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
TONS OF HAZARDOUS WASTE.
THAT'S THAT WASTE WAS
TRANSPORTED TO ONE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN FACILITIES AROUND THE
STATE FOR TREATMENT STORAGE FOR
DISPOSAL [inaudible]
LAST YEAR.
IN A THE TWENTY THREE CASES WERE
INVESTIGATED BY THE DEPARTMENT
RESULTING IN THREE EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN SETTLEMENTS AND TO
CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS.
PERMITTING AND ENFORCEMENT MUST
BE CONSISTENT TRANSPARENT
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE.
AND DTS HE MUST BE MINDFUL OF
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
PERMITTED FACILITIES ARE LOCATED
AND HAZARDOUS WASTE IS
TRANSPORTED WERE STORED.
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
THOUSANDS OF CHEMICALS ON THE
GREEN CHEMISTRY CANDIDATE
CHEMICALS LIST.
ARE USED IN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CONSUMER PRODUCTS MEANING THAT
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE EXPOSURES OF
TO THESE CHEMICALS THROUGH
MANUFACTURING USE AND DISPOSAL.
THE CONTINUED USE OF THESE
CHEMICALS GUARANTEES CONTINUE
NEED FOR HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT SITE MITIGATION SO WE
DO NEED TO BREAK THAT CYCLE.
IT SEEMS INEVITABLE THAT EACH OF
YOU HAS A STAKE IN DTS HE'S WORK
A PERMITTED FACILITY IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND ONGOING CLEAN UP A
RECENT COMMUNITY MEETING.
RELATED TO SOMETHING WE'RE
WORKING ON SO THE PARENT WHY DO
TSC MUST MEET ITS MISSION. TO
KEEP CHEMICALS FROM MIGRATING
INTO DRINKING WATER TO CLEAN UP
STATES. TO CLEAN UP STATE SITE
SLOW SO THAT THEY CAN BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION TO OUR HOUSING
PROBLEMS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HAZARDOUS WASTE IS HANDLED
PROPERLY.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN IT'S
NOT WE HOLD THOSE RESPONSIBLE.
A THOSE RESPONSIBLE ACCOUNTABLE
THROUGH EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT.
AND TO DRIVE INHERENTLY SAFER
CHEMICALS IN PRODUCT DESIGN AND
EVENTUALLY BREAK THAT CYCLE THAT
WE SEEM TO BE CAUGHT IN.
DTS THESE CHALLENGES ARE WELL
KNOWN AND HAVE BEEN ALREADY
MENTIONED TODAY ORGANIZATIONAL
TRAVELING SHOULD CHALLENGES
TRANSPARENCY IN COMMUNICATIONS
CHALLENGES.
ACCOUNTABILITY FAILURES AND
BUDGETARY CONSTRAINTS.
AMONG THOSE CHALLENGE THE MOST
URGENT IS OUR FINANCIAL HEALTH.
WITHOUT THAT WE CAN'T X. EXECUTE
TOUR MAN REQUISITE TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR NEGRI HAS
TAKEN SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO ONE
COVERS PROBLEMS WITH OUR
REPORTING.
AND TO RESTRUCTURE OUR FINANCIAL
PROGRAM UNDER NEW LEADERSHIP.
SHE ALSO WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. TO
DEVELOP ACCURATE BUDGET NUMBERS
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE WITH TO YOU
TODAY.
LAYING THE GROUNDWORK NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS DTS HE'S BUDGETARY
CHALLENGES AND DELIVER ON OUR
MISSION.
SHE WILL WALK YOU THROUGH EACH
YES HE'S BUDGET AND THE STATUS
OF OUR MAIN FUNDS.
BASED ON THE PROGRESS UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP.
DGSE CAN BEGIN THE NECESSARY
WORK TO ENGAGE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AN EXTERNAL STRAIGHT
STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE A
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING MODEL.
ALIGNED WITH STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES.
AS WE CONTINUE TO IMPROVE OUR
FISCAL PRACTICES AND REPORTING
WE WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH REGULAR
UPDATES AND SEEK YOUR INPUT ON
OUR EFFORTS.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
COMMITMENT AND MAKING SURE THE
DTS SEE AFFECTED LEE PROVIDES
PROTECTION.
AGAINST TOXICS SUBSTANCES AROUND
THE STATE.
THANK YOU WHY DON'T WE PROCEED
WITH THEM AS AN AGREE AND MISTER
MARTIN AND THEN --
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH EVERYONE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
DTS SEES BUDGET IN THE STATUS OF
OUR MAJOR FUNDS.
AS WELL AS TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE FEES THAT
SUPPORT OUR CORE PROGRAMS.
A AS THE SECRETARY INDICATED
WE'VE MADE SOME SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IS BRING CLARITY AND
TRANSPARENCY CHORE UND BALANCES
OVER THE PAST SIX MONTHS DESPITE
WELL KNOWN CHALLENGES.
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S SUPPORT IN THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS WITH
PROVIDING DTS C. THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN PROGRAM
SERVICE LEVELS.
HOWEVER WE ARE NOW FACING THE
IMPACTS OF THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS ON THE FUND BALANCES IN
OUR MAIN FUNDS THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT OR H. W.
CA.
AND THE TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ACCOUNT OR TOSCA.
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE
BEEN STRUGGLING WITH REPORTING
ACTUAL FUND BALANCES FOR SEVERAL
YEARS.
LIKE MANY OTHER DEPARTMENTS DTS
ES STRUGGLED WITH TRANSITIONING
TO FISCALE SINCE WE CONVERTED TO
THE NEW SYSTEM IN THE FISCAL
YEAR.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN CONSORTIUM
FACTORS TO THE SITUATION
INCLUDED THE COMPLEXITY OF OUR
BUDGET AND ACCOUNTING PROCESS
SEES.
AS WELL AS A LACK OF
SOPHISTICATION AND ACCOUNTING
ACCU MEN IN DTS SEES ACCOUNTING
PROGRAM.
THAT WAS NECESSARY TO HANDLE
TRANSISTOR TRANSITIONING FROM
THE PREVIOUS ACCOUNTING AND
BUDGET SYSTEM WHERE WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING FOR DECORATE DECADES
DIRECTLY TO FISCAL WITHOUT ANY
OVERLAP FOR BACKUP SYSTEM.
WE'VE TAKEN STEPS TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES AND ARE CONFIDENT
IN THE NUMBERS AND ARE FUN
CONDITIONS WHICH HAVE BEEN
VERIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THESE STEPS INCLUDE WE HIRED AN
OUT SUPPORT OUR TRANSITION
EFFORTS WE PARTNER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
RECONCILE EACH A COUNTY PERIOD --
ACTUALLY STARTING WITH THE YEAR
BEFORE WE TRANSITION TO FRISCO --
TO THE TO FIX THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE READ
RECENTLY RE OREGON WERE
REORGANIZED THE FISCAL SERVICES
PROGRAM IN DTS SEE AN
ESTABLISHED NEW LEADERSHIP OVER
THE PROGRAM WITH EXTENSIVE
BUDGETING AND ACCOUNTING
EXPERIENCE.
FINALLY WE ARE HIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES OFFICE OF
STATE AUDITS AND EVALUATION.
PROGRAM WITH SPECIFIC EXPERTISE
IN STATE ACCOUNTING PROGRAMS AND
THE SCALE TO PERFORM A FULL
AUDIT OF DTS HE'S ACCOUNTING
PROCESS SEES AND FUND MANAGEMENT.
OC IS SCHEDULED TO BEGIN THE
AUDIT IN APRIL AND THEIR
PRELIMINARY TIME LINE FOR
ISSUING REPORT IS JULY.
OF THIS YEAR.
DTS THESE PROGRAMS ARE SUPPORTED
BY MANY DIFFERENT FUNDS HOWEVER
MOST OF THE CORE PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES ARE FUNDED BY EACH W.
CA AND TOSCA.
AS YOU'RE AWARE THE NINETEEN
TWENTY JAN TEN BUDGET INCLUDES A
VERY LARGE ADJUSTMENT TO THE
FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
FUND CONDITIONS FOR THESE
ACCOUNTS.
FROM WHAT WAS REPORTED IN THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND ACTING
GALLEY. FOR EXAMPLE.
IN THE JANUARY TEN BUDGET WE
REPORTED THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
ENDING FUND BALANCE IS AN H. W.
C. EIGHT TO BE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
WHERE IS IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET IT WAS REPORTED
TO BE APPROXIMATELY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS?
BECAUSE WE WERE NOT YET CURRENT
FISCALES DTS SEE HAS BEEN
REPORTING ESTIMATES FOR ITS YEAR
AND FUND BALANCES SINCE
TRANSITIONING TO FISCALE.
WHEN WE IDENTIFY THE ABNORMALLY
HIGH FUND BALANCES PASS FALL
WHILE CLOSING FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN WE PARTNERED
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO CONDUCT A RECONCILIATION OF
EACH MONTH?
AS I INDICATED.
DURING THAT RECONCILIATION DTS
HE DETERMINED THAT ONE OF THE
CONSULTANTS WE BROUGHT ON BOARD
TO ASSIST US WITH THE TRANSITION
SOUGHT TO CORRECT A CONVERSION
ERROR AND INADVERTENTLY POSTED A
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CREDIT TO AGE TO BE CA.
THIS CONTRIBUTED TO THE LARGE
PARTY YOUR ADJUSTMENT IN FISCAL
YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AS THAT
IS CURRENTLY REFLECTED IN THE
JAN TEN BUDGET FOR H. W. CA.
THIS THERE'S BEEN CORRECTED AND
THE CURRENT AND CURRENT AND YOUR
FUND BALANCE FOR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN IS FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN H. W. CA.
WHICH IS VERY CLOSE TO WHAT WE
REPORTED LAST JUNE.
WITH TOSCO WE IDENTIFIED LAST
COUNT CONSEQUENTIAL ERRORS
HOWEVER ADJUSTMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE AND THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE JUNE ENACTMENT GALLEY AND
THE JANUARY TEN BUDGET ARE
PRIMARILY DUE TO CHANGES IN
EXPENDITURES FOR THE EXITE
PROJECT.
THE TO SEIZE CURRENT FEE
STRUCTURE WAS LAST ADJUSTED IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND IS
INSUFFICIENT TO COVER CURRENT
PROGRAM COSTS.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND
WHICH LEADS TO ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS ON BOTH DTS SEE AN FEE
PAYERS.
SOME OF THE FEE FEES HAVE A COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT SOME DO NOT.
TOTAL REVENUES ARE DEPENDENT ON
COST RECOVERY PENALTIES AND
INTEREST WHICH ARE VOLATILE AND
THE FEES THEMSELVES FLUCTUATE
ACCORDING TO ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
AND INDUSTRY PRACTICES.
IT ALSO LOCKS OF FLEXIBILITY TO
COVER SPECIFIC FUNDING NEEDS OF
VERY OVER TIME AND LEVELS OF
ACTIVITY UPON WHICH FEES ARE
BASED.
IT'S EXPENSIVE TO COLLECT THE
FEES.
CITY TEAR PHASE COSTA COLLECT
THE FEES IS APPROXIMATELY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR H.
WCAM TOSCA.
DISPROPORTIONATE FEES ARE UNFAIR
WITH SOME GENERATION GENERATORS
OF WASTE PAIN NO FEES AND OTHER
BUSINESSES SUBSIDIZING WASTE AND
WASTE MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES OF
OTHER BUSINESSES.
WE WANT TO CHANGE ALL THAT.
REVENUES HAVE NOT KEPT PACE WITH
AN INCREASE INSTEAD OPERATION
COSTS IN ADDITIONAL MANDATES.
ALTHOUGH THE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT FEE STRUCTURE WAS ADEQUATE
TO COVER THE PROGRAM COSTS THAT
EXISTED AT THAT TIME.
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE DOES NOT
SUSTAINABLY SUPPORT DTS HE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THE
ADDITIONAL MANDATES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED SINCE THAT TIME.
EXAMPLES OF MANDATES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED OVER THE YEARS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL AND FIND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING INCLUDE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GREEN
CHEMISTRY Là AB TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHICH RESULTED IN THE
CREATION OF THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY FUNDED BY TOSCA.
ADDITIONAL EXAMPLES INCLUDE IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN THE METAL
CONTAINING JEWELLERY LAW
LIMITING THE AMOUNT OF LEAD IN
JEWELRY PARTICULARLY CHILDREN'S
JEWELRY.
AND SENATE BILL THREE FORTY SIX
PROTECTING WATER QUALITY BY
REDISTRICTING COPPER AND OTHER
HEAVY METALS AND MOTOR VEHICLE
BRAKE PADS.
AND IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY THREE PERMIT
CRITERIA FOR COMMUNITY
PROTECTION.
IN IN ADDITION TO AN INCREASE IN
MANDATES BEYOND WHAT THE FEE
STRUCTURE WAS INTENDED TO COVER.
SEVERAL FACTORS INFLUENCE THE
AMOUNT OF REVENUES GENERATED BY
DTS SEE FEES SUCH AS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY JOB GROWTH CHANGES IN
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX AND
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC CONDITIONS.
IN THE PAST TWENTY YEARS THE
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED INCREASES
IN STATE OPERATIONS COSTS BUT
ABOUT PEACE THE COST OF LIVING
INCREASES THAT OUR PLIGHT TO
SOME OF THE FEES.
ACTUAL SPENDING HAS DECLINED
SIGNIFICANTLY WHEN ADJUSTED FOR
INFLATION.
AND THE NET RESULT IS DTS HE HAS
FEWER RESOURCES TODAY THAN WHEN
THE FEES FOR LAST ADJUSTED AND
THOSE RESOURCES MUST BE
STRETCHED TO ACCOMPLISH MORE.
THESE FACTORS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO A DWINDLING FUND BALANCE H.
WCAM TOSCA WHICH WE ARE NOW
WHERE CANNOT CONTINUE TO COVER
DTS HE PROGRAM COSTS.
AGE W. CA RECEIVES FEES FROM
VARIOUS HAZARDOUS WASTE
GENERATORS FACILITIES AND
TRANSPORTERS TO COVER ACTIVITIES
MANDATED BY THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL LOS.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THE
GENERATOR DISPOSAL FACILITY FEES
WERE LAST SUGGESTED IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THEIR SUBJECT TO A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT AND
COLLECTED BY THE CD TFA.
ALSO LAST UPDATED IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THE EPA ID
VERIFICATION MANIFEST USER FEES
ARE NOT ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION
AND ARE COLLECTED BY DTS SEE.
AGE W. C. ALSO RECEIVE THE
PERMIT FOR SIT FOR A PERMITTING
FEE FOR SERVICE WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED THROUGH SENATE BILL.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE IT CREATED A
FEE FOR SERVICE FOR PERMITTING
TO REIMBURSE DTS SEE FOR ACTUAL
COSTS INCURRED IN PROCESSING THE
PERMIT APPLICATIONS.
THIS CHANGE IS EXPECTED TO
LESSEN PRESSURES ON THE ACCOUNT
BUT WE WILL NOT COMPLETELY
RESOLVE IT.
AGE W. C. IS HAD A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT FOR FIVE OF THE PAST SIX
YEARS.
AND AVAILABLE FUND BALANCES
HELPED US TO SUSTAIN OPERATIONS.
ABSENT AN INCREASE IN REVENUES
THAT ARE DEPOSITED INTO AGE TO
BE CA DGSE WILL NEED TO RELY ON
COST SAVING MEASURES INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN THE
HOUSE REST WASTE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM.
TOSCA RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY 80%
OF ITS REVENUE FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FEE TO COVER THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH CLEANING
UP SITES OCATED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
INCLUDING FORMAL INDUSTRIAL
PROPERTIES SCHOOL SITES MILITARY
BASES SMALL BUSINESSES AND
LANDFILLS ALL CONTAMINATED
CONTAMINATED WITH TOXIC
SUBSTANCES.
SOME OF THESE ARE BROWN FILLED
SITES THAT OFTEN SIT IDLE OR
UNDER USED CONTRIBUTING TO BOTH
URBAN BLIGHT BROUGHT BLIGHT AND
SPRAWL.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL FEE CONSISTS
OF AN ANNUAL COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND THE REMAINING 20%
OF TOSCA RESOURCES COMES FROM
COST RECOVERY PENALTIES AND
INTEREST.
TOSSES TASK AS HAD A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT FOR FIVE OUT OF THE LAST
SIX YEARS AND HAS RELIED ON
TRANSFERS FROM NINETY TNC FUNDS
TO MEET DTS SEES MPL.
IN STATE OR FROM SIDE
OBLIGATIONS.
AS THE SECRETARY INDICATED
THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE IN
DETAILS MPO OBLIGATIONS WHICH IS
PUTTING PRESSURE ON TOSCA.
TRANSFER FROM TOSCA INTO THE
SITE REMEDIATION CAM IT BY
STATUTE TO MPL IN STATE OR FAN
SITES WERE NO RESPONSIBLE PARTY
EXISTS TO PAY FOR INVESTIGATION
AND REMEDIATION.
THE MPO PRESSURE LIKELY TO
INCREASE TO APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTEEN MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL LIKELY
RESULT IN A NEGATIVE FUND
BALANCE AND TOSCA IN THE NEAR
FUTURE.
HOWEVER WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ADDITIONAL TRANSFERS
TO THE S. R. A. BEYOND WHAT HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN TRANSFERRED
WHICH IS ABOUT TEN MILLION
ANNUALLY.
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE
ACTIVITIES AT ORPHAN SITES
AROUND THE STATE AS WELL AS
FEDERALLY FUNDED REMEDIES WILL
BE SHUT DOWN.
NEEDLESS TO SAY SHUTTING DOWN
CLEAN UP ACTIVITIES INCREASES
HEALTH SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
RISKS AND INCREASES CLEAN UP
COSTS WHEN ACTIVITIES RIVERS
THAT RESUME.
AND IN ABSENT AN INCREASE IN
REVENUE TO COVER THESE COSTS
DGSE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO FIND
IT'S FEDERALLY MANDATED AND PALE
OBLIGATIONS OR CONTINUE TO CLEAN
UP AND MAINTAIN ORPHAN SITES
AROUND THE STATE.
IT WILL ALSO BE UNABLE TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT MANDATES OF THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS DTS IS
UNDERTAKEN A NUMBER OF
INITIATIVES TO PREPARE FOR THE
FEE RESET CONVERSATION.
EXAMPLES OF THESE INCLUDE WE'VE
CONDUCTED OVER EIGHTEEN LEAN SIX
SIGMA PROJECTS WHICH ARE IN
VARIOUS STAGES OF IMPLEMENTATION
TO DECREASE TIME FRAMES FOR
DELIVERY OF OUR SERVICES AND
IMPROVE OVERALL SERVICE LEVEL.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A PERFORMANCE
MANAGEMENT AND PROGRAM REVIEW
PROGRAM TO EVALUATE PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS ASSISTED TSC WITH
ITS STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT
INITIATIVES AND MONITOR PROGRESS
ON OUR LEAN SIX SIGMA PROJECTS.
WE CONDUCTED AN ORGANIZATIONAL
HEALTH ASSESSMENT TO ESTABLISH A
BENCHMARK FOR ORGANIZATIONAL
HEALTH RECOMMENDATIONS RESULTED
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SEVERAL
INITIATIVES TO IMPROVE EMPLOYEE
PERFORMANCE AND SATISFACTION.
WE'VE IMPLEMENTED A DTS C.
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY AN INSPIRING
LEADERS PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
SUPERVISORIAL AND MANAGERIAL
EFFECTIVENESS AND TO PER.
PREPARE THE DEPARTMENT.
TO STAFF TO TAKE ON LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS IN THE FUTURE.
OR CURRENTLY CONDUCTING A
WORKLOAD ANALYSIS TO PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY ON HOW DO TIAS SEES
USING ITS RESOURCES.
AND DEVELOPING A DATA GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY WITH OUR DELIVERY
OF SERVICES.
WE'RE UPGRADING DTS THESE
EXTERNAL WEBSITE WITH THE INTENT
DEPENDING ON ADEQUATE FUNDING TO
INCLUDE A DASHBOARD TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ON KEY PERFORMANCE INDICATORS.
AND STRATEGIC INITIATIVES
PROGRESS.
AND FINALLY WE RECENTLY CREATED
A DTS THE STRATEGIC PLAN WHICH
IS CURRENTLY BEING FINALIZED
WITH THE SECRETARY'S INPUT AND
WHEN HE SAID THAT HE'S INVOLVED
IN THE DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES
WITH DTS SEE.
I CAN TELL YOU HE IS INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN ESTABLISHING THE
STRATEGIC PRIORITIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FUNDING
STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT THOSE
ACTIVITIES.
THE STRATEGIC PLAN WILL INCLUDE
KEY PERFORMANCE INDICATORS WHICH
WILL HIGHLIGHT PRIORITIES THAT
WILL FORM THE BASIS AND TIED TO
THE DEPARTMENT'S EXPENDITURE
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
AND RESOURCES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TO YOU
AND I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
MISTER MARTIN.
SONOMA.
SOMEWHERE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU CURRENT FISCAL SNAPSHOT
OF THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT AND TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL ACCOUNT.
BRIEFLY ABOUT THAT COST DRIVERS
FOR THOSE TO COUNT AND THEN --
I'M GONNA GO OVER SOME OF THE
ACTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
TAKEN TO MITIGATE THE STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN BOTH OF THOSE
ACCOUNTS BUT ONE IS START OFF BY
SAYING THAT OVER HALF OF THE
FUNDING.
IN THAT DEPARTMENT TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROLLED BUDGET FOR
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
COMES FROM THESE TWO FUNDS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY --
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROVIDED AN UPDATED FINE
CONDITION STATEMENTS.
FOR TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
COUNT HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL
ACCOUNT LAST MONDAY.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE THE NEW CONDITION
STATEMENT RECONCILE THE TWO
ACCOUNTS.
THREE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND THEIR EFFECT
UPDATED ADDRESS UPDATED
ADJUSTMENTS IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE FUN
CONDITIONS STATE FRIEND FOR THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT.
SHOWS THE YEAR AND FUND BALANCE
STEADILY DECLINING FROM PORT
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION IN. TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
NEGATIVE FIVE POINT SIX MILLION
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND NEGATIVE TWELVE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
SIMILARLY THE FUNK CONDITION
STATEMENT FOR THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT SHOWS
THE YEAR AND FUND BALANCE
STEADILY DECLINING FROM TWENTY
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION IN.
200-017-18220 TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
THIS CONTINUES A DOWNWARD TREND
THAT WE HAVE BEEN OBSERVING OVER
THE PRIOR FEW YEARS BUT WHAT WE
HAVE NOW IS MORE ACCURATE --
SENSE OF THE THAT ACTUAL
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE BECAUSE WE
HAD THESE UPDATED FROM CONDITION
STATEMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT IT'S SOMEWHAT
UNUSUAL TO BE PROVIDED A WITH A
CERTIFIED FOUND CONDITION
STATEMENTS AT THIS LATE IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS.
TYPICALLY WITH THEIR PROVIDED AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PACKAGE ON JANUARY.
TEN AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME UNCERTAINTY
SURROUNDING THE HEALTH OF THE
TWO ACCOUNTS FOR THE PAST FEW
YEARS FEW YEARS --
AND REFER TO THAT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND NAY AS WELL AS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO DRESS THESE
ISSUES.
KNOWS JUST GOING TO BRIEFLY TALK
ABOUT COST DRIVERS MUST TO THE
POINTS THAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED --
NOTE THAT SOME OF THE FACTORS
THAT HAVE INCREASING COSTS --
ARE SALLY RATED TESTAMENTS AND
BENEFIT ADJUSTMENTS FOR DTS SEE
SOME PLACE AND THAT'S IN RESULT
IN ANNUAL PROGRAM COST INCREASES --
THE STATE SHARE OF COSTS FOR
REMEDIATION IN OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE AT FEDERAL SUPERFUND
SITES IS INCREASING --
FOR EXAMPLE EXPENDITURES ARE ARE
PROJECTED --
TO GROW FROM ABOUT NINE POINT
SIX MILLION SORRY MEDIATION
ACCOUNT TO THAT EIGHTEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION ANNA IS NOTED IN
THE AGENDA WE'RE LOOKING AT CASA
THINK BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN THE
FUTURE.
IN THIS AREA.
KNOWN AS WE DISCUSSED ALREADY
THERE BEEN NEW PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES SUCH AS THE SAFER
CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM THAT
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN THEY'D
RATHER FUNDING FROM THESE
FUNDING SOURCES.
SO LASTLY I WANTED TO GO OVER
SOME OF THE FOR THE PAST FEW
YEARS IN THIS AREA THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONDUCTED A NUMBER
OF BUDGET AND OVERSIGHT HEARINGS.
TO LOOK AT THESE ISSUES --
THAT LEGISLATURE'S TABLETS
THROUGH SB EIGHTY THREE AN
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS WITH THE
GOAL OF RESOLVING.
THIS OPERATIONAL DIFFICULTIES.
ALSO AB TWO SEVENTY SIX IN --
EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY THREE HELP
THE DEPARTMENT TO ADDRESS ISSUES
REGARDING AND BUILD AND BUILD
BUT I'M COLLECTED CLEANUP COSTS
FROM RESPONSIBLE PARTIES --
SB EIGHT THIRTY NINE ELIMINATED
THE OPTION TO PAY A FLAT FEE FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE PERMIT
APPLICATION IN LIEU OF THE FEE
FOR SERVICE.
AND THE FLAT FEE OFTEN DID NOT
COVERAGE THAT DEPARTMENTS COST
TO PERFORM THE PERMIT RADIUS.
AND FINALLY --
AB TWO FORTY FIVE INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE AND CIVIL
PENALTIES FOR VIOLATIONS OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL LIES SO
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN AN ACTIVE
PARTNER WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES --
AND I WANTED INCLUDE BY SAYING
THAT WE NOW HAVE A MUCH BETTER
PICTURE OF WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS
AT THE STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE IN
THESE ACCOUNTS.
AND THAT GIVES US A MUCH BETTER
BASIS TO TRY AND DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS AND AT THE LA A WE ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
LEGISLATORS AND THEIR STAFF. TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU VERY --
WILL PROCEED WITH QUESTIONS NOW --
DOCTOR ARAMBULA WANTED TO BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MAYBE
I'LL JUST START BY SAYING I
ACTUALLY SERVE ON E. S. T. M.
AND NOT THE BUDGET SIDE.
OF SUB THREE BUT I'M ACTUALLY
GONNA FOCUS MOST OF MY COMMENTS
ON THE BUDGET BECAUSE IT'S THE
NEGATIVE BALANCE THAT TRULY IS
DISTURBING ANY OF US.
I SPENT MY LIFE WORKING IN THE
ER WHERE HE TALKED ABOT CRISIS
I KNOW A THING OR TWO ABOUT
CRISIS HAVING A NEGATIVE BALANCE
FOR THIS MANY YEARS.
THAT DID NOT HAVE BUDGET
TRANSPARENCY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IS A REAL PROBLEM
FOR MANY OF US.
A PROBLEM OF TRUST AND FEELING
LIKE WE CAN LOOK TO THIS
DEPARTMENT.
TO HELP US TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS BUT I BELIEVE FOR AT
AN INFLECTION POINT RIGHT NOW
WITH THIS CHANGE AND THE
MINISTRATIONS.
AND REALLY WANTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS WE'RE DOING THIS TRUE UP.
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAINTAIN THAT TRANSPARENCY IN
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD.
IN THAT LIGHT I REALLY WANTED TO
TALK ONCE WOULD HAVE THIS YEAR.
WHAT'S GOING TO CHANGE IF WE
DON'T HAVE GENERAL FUND CALM AND
STEP UP AND MEET YOUR NEGATIVE
BALANCE WHICH PROGRAMS ARE WE
GOING TO HALT OR STOP THE WAR.
NOT IMPLEMENT AND HOW --
BESIDES LOOKING TO GENERAL FUND
WOULD YOU MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
EITHER FROM THE DEPARTMENTS OR
TO TO MEET THAT MAKE IT A BOUNCE.
START WITH THAT IF I CAN --
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
IT IS A DIRE SITUATION TO BE A
THIS POINT IN TIME AND AND AND
TO BE IN IN THE POSITION OF OF
INCURRING A NEGATIVE SUNDANCE I
WANT TO SAY THAT WILL.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO MAKE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS --
WITH SCARCE RESOURCES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO AND CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO PROBLEM SOLVE THIS CURRENT
SITUATION.
I'M ULTIMATELY ONE THING THAT
WILL YOU ASKED THE QUESTION
WHICH PROGRAMS ARE IMPACTED AND
THE NEGATIVE FUND BALANCE
PERTAINS TO THE HAZARDS WAS
CONTROL ACCOUNT.
AND THAT ACCOUNT COVERS ALL OF
OUR ACTIVITIES THAT IMPLEMENT
THE HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL LAWS
WHICH INCLUDE.
PERMITTING WHICH INCLUDE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICE OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS --
AND SUPPORT SERVICES CREATION
AND LEGAL.
AND SOLE TIMIDLY IF WE'RE UNABLE
TO GAP THAT NEGATIVE FROM
BALLOTS WILL HAVE TO MAKE SOME
CUTS TO THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND SOMETIMES THOSE CUTS LEADS
TOWARDS DELAYS WITHIN PERMITTING
LEADS TOWARD SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT THE REST OF THE
TNC.
IS CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING.
BUT EVEN IF WE ENTER INTO THE
LARGER DISCUSSION REGARDING FEES
THOSE FEES WOULDN'T BE COLLECTED
THIS YEAR.
THAT REVENUE WOULDN'T BE
AVAILABLE TO THE NEXT YEAR AND
SO THERE'S A WHOLE THIS YEAR
THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A
BANDAID AND SOME REAL HONESTY
AND TRANSPARENCY FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENTERTAIN TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING THE NEEDS THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
BEING TASKED WITH.
SO.
IF IF I CAN HOW DO WE SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THIS YEAR.
HOW DO WE MEET THE NEEDS WITHOUT
GOING TO GENERAL FUND ARE THERE
ANY PLANS THAT YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE?
SO WE WE DO ONLY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY WE HAVE TO COLLECT THE
FEES THAT WE DO AND SO IT I
THINK.
CHIEF DIRECTOR CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR NEGRI ARTICULATED IT
WHICH IS WE WILL HAVE TO CUT.
ESPECIALLY WITHIN OUR HAZARDOUS
WASTE PROGRAM AND THAT WOULD
LEAD TO DELAYS AND PERMIT
DECISIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
MAYBE I'LL JUST END WITH THIS
THE LEGISLATURE IS A WILLING
PARTICIPANT IN WANTING TO REALLY
ENGAGE THIS ADMINISTRATION.
IN THIS DISCUSSION REGARDING
FEES SEND --
IN DOING SUCH I HOPE WE CAN ALSO
HAVE SOME INPUT INTO.
PROGRAM AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED
WITH AND DECISION MAKING SELL --
AS WE HAVE THAT LARGER
DISCUSSION AND I THINK THE
CHAIRMAN'S FOR BRING.
THIS UP TO US.
LET'S MAKE SURE WERE WORKING
TOGETHER AND COLLABORATIVELY.
TO ALLOW THIS DEPARTMENT TO HAVE
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED.
TO ENACT THE GOAL OF HELPING TO
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
ALLOW ME OF A FOLLOW UP QUESTION --
TO DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
POINTS IS THE DEPARTMENT
INTENDING TO PRESENT --
THE LEGISLATURE WITH A PLAN.
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTFALL ISSUE.
AND SO WHEN WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THAT PLAN CURRENTLY FOR THE
SPRING HAVE A ASESORíA TALKING
ABOUT MAY.
A MIKE MY CONCERN IS THIS IS
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE OF JUST
BY DEFINITION IT'S GOING TO BE --
A COMPLICATED AND PERHAPS
CONTROVERSIAL IN THAT DOES NOT
LEAVE US.
A HECK OF A LOT OF TIME.
TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT PROCESS
AROUND AROUND. TO THOSE ANYWAY
TO MOVE THAT DATE UP I THINK
THAT WOULD BE.
EXTREMELY HELPFUL.
MS GOMEZ REYES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WANT.
TO FOLLOW UP ON THE COMMENTS
FROM DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME AND I'M A
NEWCOMER THE DEPARTMENT.
IS A MESS.
THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDING THE PROTECTIONS TO
CALIFORNIANS THEY SHOULD.
HEARING TODAY ABOUT THE FACT
THAT FOR THE LAST FOR THE LAST
FIVE YEARS.
THERE HAS BEEN A DEFICIT.
YET THERE WASN'T THE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE THE REQUEST
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE US BE
INVOLVED IN THAT.
YEAH THERE'S A JOB THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
IN OUR JOB IS TO WORK WITH YOU.
IT JUST AS DR RUMBLE SAID WERE
WILLING PARTICIPANTS.
BUT IF THERE IS NO TRANSPARENCY
IF THERE IS NO [inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
THEN WE ARE LEFT IN THE DARK AND
WE ARE LEFT TO ONLY QUESTION
WHAT IS BEING DONE BECAUSE THE
ANSWERS THAT WE GET SOMETIMES
DON'T MAKE SENSE --
I I IT IN THIS IS NOT MEANT AS A
AS A CRITICISM PERSONALLY.
BUT YOU BOTH HAVE BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT.
SINCE JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SINCE DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN SO THE THE
THESE ARE ISSUES.
THAT HAVE BEEN THERE FOR SO LONG
I CAN REMEMBER WHEN I WAS
LOOKING AT A BILL THAT I WAS
INTRODUCING REGARDING.
THE THE PERMIT THE PERMITTING AN
AYE AYE HE WAS GIVING EXTRA TIME
AND WE WERE LOOKING AT THE FACT
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN VARMA SEPT
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE HIGHLIGHTED TWELVE
FACILITIES THAT WERE OPERATING
ON PERMITS THAT IT EXPIRED AS
FAR BACK AS NINETEEN NINETY TWO
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THERE ARE
STILL SOME FACILITIES THAT ARE
OPERATING A PERMITS EXTENDING AS
FAR BACK AS NINETEEN NINETY SIX
SO.
THE NINETEEN NINETY TWO ONE HAS
BEEN TAKEN CARE OF AND SO WE
STILL HAVE SOME BETTER OVER TEN
YEARS EXPIRED.
AND THAT MEANS OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
LIVING AROUND OF THESE TOXIC --
FACILITIES ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
TAKING THIS ALL IN AND WE DO
KNOW THAT IT'S THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
OF COLORS THAT ARE MOST AFFECTED.
FOR THE ONES THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED.
MY QUESTION IS WHY HASN'T.
MORE PROGRESS BEEN MADE. TO GIVE
A CLEAR MESSAGE. TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO THAT WE COULD THEN.
WORK WITH YOU.
WHAT WAS MISSING?
ALL ALL ALL ALL A DRESSER FROM
THE BUDGET PERSPECTIVE AND THEN
I'LL DEFER TO TO DOCTOR WILLIAMS
TO ADDRESS --
THE PROGRAMMATIC CAM ASPECT OF
YOUR QUESTION.
AND IN AND I DON'T WANT TO BE
DEFENSIVE IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM WE HAVE REALLY STRUGGLED
WITH TRANSITIONING INTO FISK OUT.
AND SOME OF THAT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND SOME OF THAT
IS THE NATURAL PROCESS THAT
OCCURS WHEN YOU'RE TRANSITIONING
FROM A WELL KNOWN FISCAL SYSTEM
THAT EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN USING
FOR DECADES.
INTO ONE THAT DOESN'T OPERATE
AND FUNCTION THE SAME WAY THAT
THE PRIOR ONE DID AND SO SOME OF
ITS THAT CHANGE MANAGEMENT THAT
WE STRUGGLED WITH.
SOME THAT WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
NEED TO STRENGTHEN OUR
ACCOUNTING PROCESS SEES IN OUR
ACCOUNTING PROGRAM AND HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO ESTABLISH
LEADERSHIP TO DO THAT.
WITH SPECIFIC EXPERTISE IN THE
NOW -- THAT
TAKES SOME AMOUNT OF TIME BUT WE
SPENT -- AND
I WANT.
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS BEEN OUR PARTNER IN
THIS WE SPENT THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS WITH MPLOYEES WORKING
EVERY WEEKEND TO THE HOLIDAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COULD COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH ACCURATE
FROM BALANCE NUMBERS BECAUSE WE
KNEW.
WE CAN'T START TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION INTO WE HAVE A
RECONCILIATION OF ALL OF THOSE --
ACCOUNTING PERIODS AND NUMBERS
AND SO --
YOU KNOW WITH THE CONVERSATION
DOES START WITH --
ACCURATE NUMBERS SO THAT WE KNOW
WHAT SITUATION WE HAVE WITH THE
REVENUES WHICH WERE ESTABLISHED
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO NOW FOR A
STRUCTURE THAT OR THAT EXISTED
AT THAT TME.
BUT WHICH HAS GROWN AND EVOLVED
SINCE THEN SO ALL ALL ALL
DEFERRED A DOCTOR WILLIAMS FOR
ANY PROGRAMMATIC RESPONSE
[inaudible]
SO.
THOSE THAT KNOW ME KNOW THAT MY
FORMER CEO USED TO SAY.
GOOD NEWS IS NO NEWS.
NO NEWS IS BAD NEWS AND BAD NEWS
IS GOOD NEWS AND I IS HERE TO
THAT I'M HAPPY TO EXPLAIN THAT
FURTHER IF ANYBODY CARES.
BUT THE IDEA THAT BAD HERE TO IT
NOW THOUGH YEAH WELL BAD NEWS IS
GOOD NEWS MEANS THAT THAT MEANS
COMMUNICATION IS HAPPENING THAT
MEANS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
REAL PROBLEM IS ON THE TABLE.
THAT MEANS YOU CAN ACTUALLY
ENGAGE IN THE SOLUTIONS IN
FINDING THE SOLUTIONS AND THAT
HAS BEEN MY MODEL FOR MORE THAN
A DECADE AND IT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE MY MODEL.
I ALSO THINK THAT THE SECRETARY
ALLUDED TO THE FACT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ACROSS THE BOARD
ISM IS.
COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY WANTS
TO HAVE A REAL DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE REAL ISSUES.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO YOU KNOW ALL OF
THE REASONS AND ALL THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WERE SHE TO
SHARE INFORMATION IN THE PAST
WHERE.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO COME WITH A
BELIEVE IT WAS SENATOR ALLEN WHO
SAID THAT OR MAYBE IT WAS LIKE
HAVE SKIS ABOUT BEING A DOCTOR
AND YOU CAN BE A GREAT DOCTOR
BUT YOU'RE NOT AN ACCOUNTANT.
I GOT TO TELL YOU FROM DOCTOR
AND I'M RUNNING A BUSINESS AND
MY NUMBERS AREN'T MATCHING AND
I'M NOT TAKING HOME SALARY I'M
GOING TO FIGURE OUT WHO I HIGHER
TO MAKE SURE THEY TAKE CARE OF
THE NUMBERS.
WE DON'T HAVE TO BE EXPERTS IN
EVERYTHING AND THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS.
AND THAT'S FOR ME THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT AND IS.
IT'S A RHETORICAL QUESTION BUT I
REALLY TO WANT TO HEAR THE
ANSWER.
IS THERE A SENSE OF URGENCY IN
ADDRESSING THIS PROBLEM.
IF YOU CENTERS RHETORICAL BUT
THAT.
IT YES.
YES AGAIN EVERY DAY WERE ENGAGED
WITH THE SECRETARY EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
ALL RIGHT WE WE WILL CLEARLY BE
A BE ON THIS BECAUSE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT.
AND YOU KNOW MIGHT MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AND SHE'S
LIVING IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF
THIS MORE SO THAN MANY OF US.
BUT I DO THINK YOU I I I THANK
YOU FOR THE LEADERSHIP I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO PROVIDE.
A WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT
WE REALLY ARE I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
DOCTOR QUIRK FOLLOWED BY --
MS GARCIA AND MISTER ALLEN.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE BAD NEWS --
I I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
COMING FORWARD AND DISCLOSING
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION.
I ALSO WANT TO SAY WE WE CANNOT
AFFORD TO MAKE CUTS.
IN THE YOUR PERSONNEL THAT
THINGS ARE --
ASUS LEVEL ALREADY --
AND I AGREE WITH THAT CHAIR --
BLOOM THAT WE NEED --
TO SUPPLEMENT YOUR BUDGET AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN TO PREVENT
CUTS.
AND HOPEFULLY TO GET TO THE
RESOURCES YOU NEED SO YOU DON'T
HAVE --
PERMITS THAT GO TWENTY YEARS IF
THE RESOURCES ARE REALLY ONE OF
THE REASONS.
ARE THERE OTHER REASONS THAT
PERMITS CAN TAKE TWENTY YEARS.
SO I THINK THAT ACROSS THE BOARD
IN THE DEPARTMENT WE HAVE
CHALLENGES MAKING DECISIONS --
THERE ARE TOUGH DECISIONS TO BE
MADE THEY NEED TO BE MADE THEY
NEED TO BE DONE IN A TIMELY
FASHION THEY NEED TO BE MADE
BASED ON STE ON SOUND SCIENCE.
AND IT TAKES INTESTINAL
FORTITUDE TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS IN A TIMELY FASHION
AND THAT'S PROBABLY OUR BIGGEST
OPPORTUNITY IS JUST TO GET TO
THE DECISION POINT.
SOME OF THAT WILL HAPPEN THROUGH
OUR NEW VIOLATIONS SCORING.
PROCEDURES WHICH REALLY --
PROVIDE SOME CONSISTENCY AROUND
WHAT WE'RE WHAT CONSTITUTES A
VIOLATION THAT WOULD HAVE AN
IMPACT ON HOW WE WHERE PERMIT
DECISION I THINK THAT WILL
ACTUALLY HELP US.
GET TO THOSE DECISIONS IN A
CONSISTENT WAY M..
OF ACTIVELY BUT WE ALSO HAVE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES JUST TO TO
GET TO THAT DECISION POINT --
QUICKLY SO THAT'S PROBABLY THE
NUMBER ONE THING I THINK WE CAN
DO ACROSS THE BOARD --
ARE THESE DECISIONS BEING HELD
UP BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE WORRIED
ABOUT SUITS AND SO THEY WANT TO
MAKE THINGS PERFECT.
I THINK.
I THINK THAT BIG LEGAL CALCULUS
ALWAYS GOES INTO THINGS BUT WE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES GET SUED.
IT'S THE NATURE OF THE BEAST.
AND THAT'S LET US KNOW IF THERE
IS A WAY WE CAN HELP YOU.
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO ADD TO THAT
WE ALSO HAD BUSINESS PROCESS.
AND THE PERMIT DECISION.
STRUCTURE THAT WERE ANTIQUATED
AND THAT HAD NEEDED UPDATING AND
AS THE SECRETARY NDICATED HE'S
BIG ON LEAN.
MANY OF OUR PROJECTS RELATE TO
THE PERMITTING PROCESS ARE LEAN
SIX SIGMA PROJECTS RELATE TO THE
PERMITTING PROCESS AND WE'VE
SEEN SOME SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS --
IN THE PILOTING OF NEW PROCESSES
THAT WERE CURRENTLY UPDATING
WHICH SHOULD RESULT IN --
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN TIME
FRAMES FOR DECISION MAKING
PROCESS THE DECISION MAKING A
PERMANENT ALONG WITH --
VIOLATIONS GREEN PROCEDURE THAT
DOCTOR WILLIAMS IF YOU CAN MAKE
A SUCCESS OF THESE --
WE WELCOME TO HAVE YOU BACK AND
TELL US HOW YOU MANAGE TO GET SO
I HOPE THAT.
YOU CAN TELL US ABOUT SUCCESSES --
PERHAPS A YEAR FROM NOW THANK
YOU [inaudible]
GARCIA.
THANK YOU I WOULD FOR A AS MY
QUESTION I EIGHTY ONE A ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
MYSTERY IS ABOUT PERMITS THAT
ARE OUT THERE.
FOR TEMPERATURES HAVE BEEN OUT
THERE FOR TEN YEARS --
AND SO EVERY FOR IN OUR FROM
BACKSIDE WE SEE THE DANGERS
THERE.
ARE AND AND WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT EXCEPT BUT ALSO WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT EXIT IS ONE OF MANY
ISSUES IN MY BACKYARD IT'S
COMMUNITIES INTO LIKE A
WASTELAND LONG BEFORE I WAS
ELEVEN THAT'S IN FORTY TWO YEARS.
LAW AND SO YOU KNOW I HAVE A LOT
OF INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
EXCITED STONE PROPERLY AND WE
LEARN FROM THAT ALL WE CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT MOVING FORWARD
WILL TO DO ALL THE OTHER CLEAN
UP ANY SAPONIN.
IN MY BACKYARD WE WE HAD AN
AUDIT IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
ABOUT DTC AND THEIR FAILURE TO
COLLECT ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FEES OUT THERE AND BECAUSE
I'M WORRIED ABOUT HOW THE
BATTERY FEE BILL IS BEING USED --
AND AND BECAUSE I WANT TO BE A
PARTNER AT WHAT I HAVEN'T HEARD
IS.
WHAT ARE SOME IDEAS WE HAVE TO
START COLLECTING THAT I WAS
STARTING TO DO THAT I KNOW WE'VE
GIVING IT ALREADY SO THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
START COLLECTING FEES?
FROM FOLKS TO RECOVER COST HOW
AGGRESSIVE ARE WE DOING THAT OF
LEARNING AND WE HAVE AN EXTRA
STARTED MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION
YET.
SO THAT THEIR TWO PIECE OF THAT
I THINK --
ONE WOULD BE OUR COST RECOVERY
EFFORTS AND THE OTHER WOULD BE
OUR FEE FOR SERVICE WORK --
AND FOR SMALL COST RECOVERY WE
LEARNED A LOT WE'VE CHANGED OUR
PROCEDURES AND WE NOW WILL AGAIN
IT'S ABOUT DECISION MAKING
MAKING A DECISION MUCH MORE
QUICKLY ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S EVEN WORTH PURSUING.
IF THE IF THE RESPONSIBLE PARTY
ISN'T THERE IN THIS THE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THAT WE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO RECOVER.
ISN'T WORTH THE EFFORT WE ARE
GOING TO PUT THE EFFORT INTO IT
WE HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES.
SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO PURSUE
THAT BUT WE DID.
OVERHAUL OUR COST RECOVERY
PROCEDURES AND THOSE ARE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW
AND THEY'RE WORKING EFFECTIVELY --
WITH RESPECT TO FEE FOR SERVICE
THAT ALSO IS IN PLACE WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE --
THE THE REVENUE FROM THAT NEW
APPROACH --
COME IN AND I'M GOING TO LET.
FRANCESCA NEVER TALK ABOUT.
BRIGHT SO WE ARE --
WERE YOU AS A DOCTOR OWN
SYNDICATE WE ARE STARTING TO SEE
REVENUES COME IN FOR FEE FOR
SERVICE I BELIEVE AND THIS I
THINK WE'VE BUILD --
OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN FEE
FOR SERVICE --
FOR THIS FISCAL YEAR AND AND ARE
HAVE COLLECTED OVER ONE
SOMEWHERE AROUND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO WE'RE STARTING TO SEE --
COME IN FROM THAT PROGRAM THAT
ARE COVERING THE COST OF ON THE
PERMIT WRITERS IN THAT PROGRAM
AND THAT DOES LESSEN THE
PRESSURE ON EACH W. CA --
WITH RESPECT TO I WANTED TO
ADDRESS --
AND PROVIDE YOU WITH SOME
INFORMATION ON THE PERMANENT
SIDE OF BEEN --
EXPIRED MORE THAN TEN YEARS TO
TO GIVE YOU A STATUS ON THAT.
AND THE EXPIRATION --
FOR THREE PERMITS OR MORE IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX TWO THOUSAND
FOUR IN TWO THOUSAND SIX A
DECISION FOR ONE OF THOSE
PERMITS HIS PLAN FOR FISCAL YEAR.
NINETEEN TWENTY SEQUEL E. I.
OURS ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED FOR
THE TWO REMAINING PROJECTS AND
THOSE DECISIONS ARE PLAN FOR
FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE
BEGINNING OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO ALL PERMITS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE EXPIRED FROM
NORMAL NO MORE.
THAN THREE TO FIVE YEARS AND 90%
OF PERMIT DECISIONS ARE EXPECTED
WITHIN TWO YEARS ASSUMING
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES ARE IN
PLACE SO.
THOSE ARE OUR GOALS TO ELIMINATE
THE BACKLOG OF THOSE PERMITS
HAVE BEEN EXPIRED FOR FOR YEARS
AND YEARS.
WHAT A SECOND I TAKE UNTIL?
NO MULTI PLAYER SOMETIME YOU
HAVE A PLAN WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
HEAR.
SOMETHING YOU FOR THE APPLE WISE
THE PLANNED SO MANY YEARS STILL
IN THE MAKING.
I'M I'M HAPPY TO BRING UP THE
EXPERTISE AND PERMITTED TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHY THOSE
PARTICULAR PERMIT --
FACILITIES ARE SO COMPLICATED TO
PERMIT -- I
DON'T HAVE THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE MYSELF AND I'M HAPPY
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH THE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT AS AS WERE.
TRYING TO DO THE BACK BLOCK I
UNDERSTAND NOT CUTTING C<c.cyan> --</c>
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING STUCK ON PERFECT --
AND WE'RE DOING GOOD ENOUGH
BECAUSE OF BOB OR WAITING WITH
THAT MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE.
GETTING SICK KINDA AND PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT THAT IS TIED.
UP WITH WITH THAT AND SO --
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOUR MAILING
OUT THESE BILLS WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY PAYING THESE BILLS
WITH US OF THE PARTY WITH THE
AUTO FOUND THAT WHILE WE MAILED
OUT BILLS WE WHAT.
DO ANYTHING TO MAKE SURE THOSE
BILLS WERE BEING PAID.
WE WE FOLLOW UP WITH --
NOTICES TO THEM THE FEE PAYERS --
AT REGULAR INTERVALS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WERE COST RECOVERY IN
EARLY CHECKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT SYSTEM IS WORKING YES AND
WE ALSO REFER OVER TO OUR LEGAL
DIVISION WHEN WE HAVE ISSUES
WITH WITH THREE PAYMENT NOR.
WITH [inaudible]
YEAH THINKING [inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
YEAH I'D LIKE TO JUST TAKE DOWN
A LITTLE BIT INTO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT THE EXPENSE ASSOCIATED
WITH COLLECTING THE FEES.
AND KIND OF UNDERSTANDING OF WHY
THAT IS AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP YOU GET MORE AGGRESSIVE
ABOUT GOING AFTER THOSE FOLKS
WHO REALLY OUGHT TO BE PAYING
FOR YOUR PROGRAM --
IS YOUR QUESTION RELATED TO THE
COST OF COLLECTING THE THE FEES
THEMSELVES WE ARE.
WAS MAJOR THE TFA I I THINK I
MADE THE COMMENT THAT --
H. W. C. AND TOSCA FEES SOME OF
THOSE ARE COLLECTED BY CITY TFA
AND IT'S IT'S AT AN ANNUAL COST
OF SIX MILLION DOLLARS --
AND THEN DTS C. COLLECTS A FEW
OF THE FEES ITSELF SO WE ARE
ACTUALLY EVALUATING --
THE AND AND DOING A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS ON ON WHETHER OR NOT IT
MAKES MORE SENSE FOR D. TSC TO
COLLECT THOSE HE'S DIRECTLY --
OR CONTINUE TO WERE CITIES.
OKAY BUT WHAT WHY IS IT SO
EXPENSIVE.
YOU MENTIONED THAT.
WELL I WOULD YOU KNOW I I I I
DON'T --
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE COST
MECHANISMS THAT GO INTO CD TO
HAVE FACE FEE STRUCTURE --
I DO KNOW THAT THOSE AMOUNTS
SEEM HIGH TO ME IN TERMS OF THE
ANNUAL COST --
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE BILL THE
DEPARTMENT FOR COLLECTION OF
THOSE FEES.
WHO'S CALLING YOU AGAIN IT'S IN
THE CALIFORNIA TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION IS TO BE THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION ARE THEY
OKAY ARE THE IT IS AT ANY MORE
THAN THE BILL OTHER PEOPLE OR IS
IT HAS SOMETHING TO DO WITH --
WITH -- IT
DOES THAT IS THAT IS THAT A
FORMULA OR YOUR WITH WHAT
THEY'RE WHAT THEY'RE BILLING
PRACTICES ARE WITH OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS BUT AS I INDICATED
WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING A LOOK
AT AND CURRENTLY A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS ON THAT COSTUME AGAINST
COLLECTING THE CITY'S OURSELVES.
YEAH I LOVE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THAT MYSELF AND IF IT'S A MATTER
OF PROVIDING YOU WITH GREATER
FORCE A MECHANISM --
POWERS OR OR IF IT'S A MATTER
BETTER COORDINATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE OR SOME SORT
OF THERE IS LITTLE CHATTER ON
THE DíAS WHEN YOU MADE THAT
COMMENT AND ONE OF THE COMMENTS
SOMEONE MADE TO ME --
UNDER THEIR BREATH WAS THAT --
YOU KNOW THAT DID DATE SOME OF
THESE FOLKS SOME OF THE
POLLUTERS BASICALLY TIE YOUR
KNOTS -- ITO --
CHALLENGING EVERY EVERY FEE --
DECISION [inaudible]
AND YOU NOT LEAD TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THAT AND AND
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN GIVE YOU
THE ENFORCEMENT TOOLS YOU NEED.
TO BE ABLE TO GO AFTER THESE
POLLUTERS.
SO I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY APPRECIATES AT
SUPPORT LET ME DIFFERENTIATE AND
THEN MAYBE CLARIFY MY COMMENT --
I'M I WASN'T REFERRING --
TO THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES THAT
ARE NECESSARY.
TO COLLECT COST RECOVERY WHICH
IS -- A
REVENUE ELEMENT OF BOTH H. W. CA
AND TOSCA AND WHICH IS A
VOLATILE.
REVENUE SOURCE WHICH CONTRIBUTES
TO SUPPORTIVE OF THE COST OF THE
PROGRAMS I WAS REFERRING TO THE
COLLECTION OF THE ESTABLISHED
FEES THE DISPOSAL FEE THE
GENERATOR FEE.
AND AND THE SECRETARY REFERENCE
AT SOME OF THESE FEES ARE --
WE HAVE MULTIPLE FEES THAT HIT
THE SAME FEE PAYER AND THEY'RE
CONFUSING TO THE FEE PAYERS AND
THOSE WITH THE FEES THAT I WAS
REFERRING TO THAT CD TFA
COLLECTS.
COST RECOVERY IS WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT BILLS DIRECTLY TO
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES AND THAT'S
AS YOU WERE FOR HER CAN RESULT
IN DELAYS IN PAYMENTS AND
LITIGATION WHEN THERE'S A
RESISTANCE --
TO REIMBURSING THE DEPARTMENT
FOR OUR ARE BILLED AMOUNTS AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE MORE VOLATILE BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE WON'T RECEIVED --
THE PAYMENT --
IN THE BUDGET YEAR THAT WE AND
BUILD IT OR WE MAY GET INTO
LITIGATION TO COLLECT THOSE
COSTS SO I I THINK.
THERE'S THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT.
PARTS OF FEES WERE TALKING ABOUT
IN TERMS OF THE EXPENSE TO
COLLECT AND CD HERE PHASE WORK
IS NOT IS RELATIVELY ROUTINE
RIGHT.
IT'S NOT EXCEPTIONAL THEY'RE NOT
HAVING TO GO OUT AND DO A LOT OF
ENFORCEMENT AND FOLLOW UP ON
FEES THESE ARE THE NORMAL BREAD
AND BUTTER FEES THE OKAY SO BUT
BUT ARE THEY IS THERE SOMETHING
ABOUT.
YOUR INDUSTRY.
THAT.
LEADS TO A HIGHER FEE COLLECTION
STRUCTURE OR IS THIS WHAT
THEY'RE CHARGING ALL OF THE
AGENCIES.
THAT THEY DO THIS WORK WITH.
SO WHEN WE DO THAT COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THAT'S A KEY QUESTION
FOR US OKAY OKAY WHAT WHY.
SO I'M INTERESTED IN THAT AND
I'M ALSO INTERESTED --
SO TO BE VERY JIM TO SEE THIS
DIFFERENTIATION.
MAYBE IT HAS TO DO WITH --
JUST THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
AND THERE'S ASPECTS OF THAT THAT
WE DON'T FULLY UNDERSTAND WILL
BE INTERESTING TO SEE.
IF THERE'S A FAX FOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH GOING AFTER
PHOBIA WITH GETTING.
FEES FROM THE FROM THE TOXICS.
AREA RATHER THAN FROM.
OTHER AREAS OF STATE REGULATION --
ON THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE FAA
THAT THE OTHER THING I LOVE.
TO KIND OF LEARN MORE ABOUT IS
AS YOU GET.
DEEPER INTO THIS ANALYSIS ARE
THERE TOOLS THAT YOU NEED.
I THAT WILL MAKE IT EASIER
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO PROVIDE
EVERYONE TO PROCESS AND AND
ALLOW FOLKS.
TO YOU KNOW --
TO WE WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE
YOU KNOW THE YOU'RE SO
APPROPRIATELY THAT THAT'S
VITALLY IMPORTANT --
BUT IF.
IF THEY'RE YOU KNOW THàNH YOU
UP IN KNOTS ON NECESSARILY AND
AND HAMPERING YOUR ABILITY TO DO
YOUR WORK --
YOU KNOW --
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT TOO
AND AND TAKE.
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE TOOLS YOU NEED. TO
HOLD FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO ASSIST WITH
THAT.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING GOT TOPIC
BECAUSE A YEAR ESSENTIALLY IN
THE POSITION OF BEING OUT.
ONE STATE AGENCY.
ASKING ANOTHER WHY A CHARGING
SO MUCH HA AND SIX MILLION
DOLLARS --
ISN'T --
ISN'T CHICKEN FEED --
BUT DO YOU HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONDUCT --
WHAT AMOUNTS TO A THIS IS A?
SEEMS LIKE IT IT DEMANDS KIND OF
AN AUDIT WHERE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
LOOKING --
INTO THE PROCESSES OF THE OTHER
AGENCY AND UNDERSTANDING HOW IT
COMES TO PASS THAT THEY CHARGED
THE THESE.
SO WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT FUNCTIONALITY WE
NEED WITHIN OUR OWN SYSTEM
BEFORE ALREADY COLLECTING SOME
FEES.
THEN WHAT WOULD WE NEED TO WE
NEED A LEGISLATIVE CHANGES IT IN
STATUTE THAT WE USE --
FORMALLY BE --
YOU KNOW CITY TFA TO COLLECT
THOSE FEES --
DO WE NEED A LEDGE PROPOSAL TO
BE AND WHAT WOULD THE COST TO
THE DEPARTMENT BE TO COLLECT THE
CITY'S OURSELVES AND HOW WOULD
THAT BE THAT D USE THAT THE
BURDEN THAT STRUCTURALLY WHAT
YOU WOULD NEED TO DO IN ORDER --
TO CHANGE --
YOUR MECHANISM IF THAT'S
INDICATED THE QUESTION I HAVE
GETS MORE AT WHETHER IT'S
ACTUALLY INDICATED OR NOT AND
HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT WITHOUT
KIND OF PEELING BACK THE LAYERS
OF THE ONION AND LOOKING.
CLOSELY AT HOW THE FEES ARE
BEING DETERMINED AND AND TO
CHARGE CITY SKI TSA.
SO I THINK THAT WILL BE PART OF
THE ANALYSIS IS JUST ASKING CD
TFA FOR COST BREAKDOWN OF THEIR
SERVICES TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
YOU KNOW IT ANALYZE IT FOR
APPROPRIATENESS AND FAIRNESS AND
I I HOPE AND I DON'T MEAN.
TO CAST ASPERSIONS ON THE OTHER
AGENCY BUT I I HOPE THAT IT WILL
BE A CRITICAL ANALYSIS.
IN THIS POWER CAN.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE HEARD THIS DEGREE SAY
A COUPLE TIMES --
IS THAT THE FEES THIS NOT.
FAIR WHEN THEY'RE NOT BEING
ASSESSED EQUALLY IN THE WAY YOU
THINK THEY SHOULD BE I WANT TO
FIRST CHECK ON MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS THAT.
YOU KNOW AS WERE BEING ASKED TO
PUT MORE GENERAL FUND MONEY INTO
THIS TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS OBVIOUSLY
CRUCIAL.
YOU KNOW THE COLLECTION IF HE'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BUT WE NEED TO
KNOW THAT FROM START TO FINISH
THIS PROCESS IS WORKING THE WAY
IT SHOULD BE --
AND THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE IN
PARTNERSHIP IN UNDERSTANDING
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH FIXES NEED
TO HAPPEN AND HOW WE CAN BOTH
PROTECTOR COMMUNITIES FROM THE
IMPORTANT WORK.
LUCIEN IT IS OUT THERE AND
YOU'RE ABLE TO DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK YOU'RE TASKED TO DO BUT
THAT IT'S BEEN DONE IN A WAY
THAT'S FAIR AND EQUITABLE SO CAN
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT THE AS THE
FEES THAT ARE ASSESSED IN THE
EQUITY.
THERE.
SURE OF COURSE WELL I THINK THAT
I THINK THE SECRETARY OPENED UP
THAT -- THAT.
THAT LINE WITH HIS COMMENT THAT
SOME FEE PAYERS ARE PAYING --
FOR YOU KNOW OTHER BUSINESSES
WASTES AND THE LIKE AND SO AGAIN
THIS FEE STRUCTURE WAS CREATED
BACK IN OUT OF A TASK FORCE --
IN --
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN IT WAS
CREATED --
YOU KNOW DID THE BEST JOB COULD
AT THAT TIME TO CREATE THIS FEE
STRUCTURE FOR THE ORGANIZATION
THAT EXISTED AT THAT TIME.
AND THE FEES HAVE AND SO YOU
HAVE SOME BUSINESSES THAT
ACTUALLY CREATE HAZARDOUS WASTE
IT PAY NO FEE AND THEN YOU HAVE
SOME BUSINESSES THAT PAY.
FEES IN A VARIETY OF AREAS SUCH
AS THE SECRETARY REFERENCED YOU
KNOW A A FACILITY MIGHT PAYYOU
KNOW OF FACILITY FEE IN A PERMIT
FEE AND AND MULTIPLE FEES TO
COVER.
THE HAZARD THEIR ACTIVITIES
UNDER THE HOUSES WAS CONTROL US
NOW THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE ALL
VERY SEPARATE AND DISTINCT.
BUT IT MAKES THE WHOLE STRUCTURE
OF BIT CONFUSING AND SO --
WE WOULD LIKE TO PARTNER WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE FEE STRUCTURE AS IT IS
TODAY TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT IT
ALIGNS WITH YOU KNOW THE LEVEL
OF PROTECTION --
THAT AND WE M. AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION WANT TO PROVIDE
IN TERMS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND PROTECTION OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AND DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT AND
MAKE DECISIONS ON WHETHER OR NOT
THAT THE STRUCTURE SUPPORTS THAT
THAT PROGRAM INTEGRITY AND LEVEL
OF SERVICE.
THANK YOU I MEAN I JUST WANNA.
TAKE ONE MOMENT AND SAY I
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE OBVIOUSLY ARE
ALWAYS LOOKING AT THE EQUITY
WITH WHICH WE ASSESS ALL FEES IN
CALIFORNIA --
BUT AGAIN AS WE LOOK AT PUTTING
MORE MONEY AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE INSURE THAT
THAT WAS CONSTANT COMMUNICATION
THAT THIS ISN'T BROUGHT UP WHEN
WE'RE IN THE DIRE STRAITS WE'RE
IN TODAY.
BUT THAT WE UNDERSTAND ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WHAT'S HAPPENING
WHY IT'S HAPPENING AND HOW OUR
MONEY IS BEING SPENT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOMEZ REYES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IN RESPONSE TO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA.
YOU MENTIONED THAT.
IF YOU HAVE THE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES YOU'LL BE ABLE TO DO
THE WORK.
WHAT ARE THE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES AND THE REASON I ASK
IS THAT?
WE'VE JUST HAD A LONG
CONVERSATION REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL SHUFFLING THE FUNDS TO
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL CHALLENGES.
I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT.
IN THREE YEARS WILL BE BACK HERE
AND WE'LL BE TOLD THE REASON WE
DIDN'T DO IT IS BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES.
IS THERE A PLAN THAT IS BEING
PUT TOGETHER.
WHEN WILL THAT PLAN I I KNOW
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE AUDIT WE
TALKED ABOUT ANALYSIS?
IS THERE A PLAN BEING PUT
TOGETHER THAT IS GOING.
TO TAKE US FROM POINT A TO POINT
B. THAT YOU ARE.
SO THE NEWS DEPARTMENT CAN WORK
IN A MORE PROGRAMMATIC --
WAY -- THAT
IS THAT IS.
THE TAKES CARE BUSINESS AND IN
THE MORE FISCAL WAY --
THAT ALLOWS YOU --
TO COLLECT THE FEES THAT YOU
NEED TO COLLECT BUT TO BE ABLE
TO BE A SUCCESSFUL --
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE AS I THINK
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
IT'S THE CALIFORNIANS WERE GOING
TO SUFFER FROM.
THE WORK THAT IS BEING THAT IS
NOT BEING DONE --
AND I THE THE I'M NOT SAYING
IT'S FINGER POINTING --
AND EAT THE THAT IT WAS A GOING
BACK TO THE TRANSPARENCY ISSUE.
AND I I ECHO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
HAS JUST TALKED ABOUT.
WE DON'T HAVE THE TRANSPARENCY
WE DON'T HAVE THE TRUST AND YET
THERE'S A COMMENT ABOUT HAVING
MORE FUNDS PROVIDED TO YOU SO
YOU CAN DO YOUR JOB.
THEN THE QUESTION IS.
WHY WEREN'T WE TOLD ABOUT THIS
BEFORE WHAT'S THE PLAN ON HOW
THIS IS GOING TO BE SPENT?
UP HOW WOULD WE TAKE CARE OF NOW
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE
PROBLEMS IN THE FUTURE.
AND I'D LIKE TO END WITH JUST.
WE'VE TALKED A WHOLE LOT ABOUT --
THE H. W. CA.
A SHORT FORM --
WE UNDERSTAND THAT'S IT THAT
FUND IS MORE URGENT.
BUT THIRTY SCA IS ALSO ALSO HAS
A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT --
THE NEW FUND CONDITION
STATEMENTS MIGHT GO INTO A
NEGATIVE IN 202-020-2020.
ONE ABSENT ACTION THIS YEAR AND
CALLS AGAIN IS THE DEPARTMENT
DEVELOPING A PLAN TO ALSO
ADDRESS THE LOOMING NEGATIVE.
DEFICIT OF THE TS SCA ACCOUNT.
I KNOW IT'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
YEAH A LOT OF CONCERN
[inaudible]
THE I I WANNA I WANNA REFER BACK
TO THE SECRETARY'S COMMENTS
WHERE HE IS --
INDICATED HE'S AND PARTNERING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT --
TO IDENTIFY YOU KNOW GET A
BASELINE FOR WHAT LEVEL OF
SERVICE WE CAN PROVIDE WITH
CURRENT RESOURCES WE HAVE AND HE
INDICATED THAT WE WERE A FEW
MONTHS OUT WITH THAT AND THAT.
TIES TO AND OUR WORKLOAD
ANALYSIS THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
HAVE UNDER WAY IN THE DEPARTMENT
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT --
THE EM.
IF AN I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION FOR THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS WITH PROVIDING RESOURCES
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE.
PROGRAM ISSUES WE BROUGHT TO
YOUR ATTENTION THE LEGISLATURE'S
BEEN A VITAL PARTNER WITH DTC
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS ON
PERMITTING AND IN PARTICULAR AND
IF YOU RECALL --
DE AND LEGISLATURE --
APPROVED FOR SOME PERMANENT
POSITIONS WITH LIMITED TERM
FINDING SOME OF WHICH WERE TO
SUPPORT THE PERMITTING PROCESS
AND THAT'S WHAT I WAS REFERRING
TO WE'VE HAD --
A GREAT DEAL OF SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE HONOR PERMITTING
PROGRAM WE'VE HAD SOME PERMANENT
POSITIONS THAT ARE TIED TO THE
FEE FOR SERVICE.
AND THE RESOURCES THAT I WAS
REFERRING TO THAT WERE NECESSARY
IN ORDER FOR US TO MEET 90% OF
OUR PERMITS WITHIN TWO YEARS ARE
RELATED TO THE SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THAT WERE ESTABLISHED AS
PERMANENT POSITIONS.
BUT LIMITED TERM FUNDING BECAUSE
OF THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE H. W. CA WAS IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THAT WE
WERE WAITING --
FOR THE CLARITY ON THE FUND
BALANCES IN ORDER TO TAKE TO
PARTNER WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THAT PARTICULAR SITUATION SO
WE'VE MADE --
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS ON
THE PERMITTING BUSINESS
PROCESSES TO IMPROVE
EFFICIENCIES ULTIMATELY --
WE STILL ARE SHY RESOURCES IN
SOME OF OUR SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND
WHAT I'M REFERRING TO IS
ENFORCEMENT IN LEGAL --
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THAT AND
AND PROCESS FOR THE PERMIT
ISSUANCE IS FULLY IS FULLY
SUPPORTED --
TO YOUR QUESTION OF WHETHER OR
NOT WE ARE DEVELOPING A A PLAN
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IT'S A BRAND NEW
ADMINISTRATION SO.
THE TSC IS --
WORKING COOPERATIVELY IN CLOSELY
AND INTENSELY AND WITH URGENCY
ON SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF THAT LARGER
PLAN ABOUT WHAT PROGRAMS SUPPORT
REALLY LOOKS LIKE WHAT DOES A
HEALTHY DEPARTMENT LOOK LIKE AS
AS THE SECRETARY LOOTED TO THERE
ARE NUMBER OF PIECES TO THAT SO.
THERE WAS REFERENCE TO OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN IN THAT STRATEGIC
PLAN WE TALK ABOUT WHAT WE THINK.
IT SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT IS
FUNCTIONING AS A HEALTHY
DEPARTMENT WHAT KINDS OF
SERVICES DO WE PROVIDE WHAT CAN?
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT US TO
DELIVER SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
PICTURE.
YOU HAVE TO THE PICTURE OF OUR
STATUTORY MANDATES AND WHAT
WE'RE REQUIRED TO DO UNDER THE
LAW.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A GOOD PICTURE
OF OUR FIRST FISCAL POSITION.
AND WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND OUR
THIS THIS WORKLOAD ANALYSIS WHAT
IT WHAT WE THINK --
WHAT DO WE KNOW BASED ON DATA IT
TAKES TO DO?
THE JOB.
AND WHEN YOU BRING THE THEN YOU
GET THE COMPREHENSIVE PICTURE OF
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
WHAT IT WOULD LOOK LIKE TO
SUPPORT AN EFFECTIVE HEALTHY DTS
SEE?
AND UNTIL WE BRING ALL THOSE
ELEMENTS TOGETHER WE WE WON'T
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE.
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT OF A NEW
REVISED FEE STRUCTURE WOULD LOOK
LIKE AND WHAT ADEQUATE FUNDING
WOULD WOULD BE TO MEET OUR
MANDATE.
AND FINALLY IF I MAY.
AS ACTING DIRECTOR.
I REITERATE WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WE ARE
WILLING PARTICIPANTS WE NEED THE
TRANSPARENCY WE NEED TO REBUILD
THAT TRUST.
YOU ARE IN A NEW POSITION AND
YOU GET TO LEAD THE DEPARTMENT
EVEN IF IT'S HONORED ON AN
INTERIM BASIS.
AND WE ARE HERE TO BE YOU'RE
WILLING PARTNERS THANK YOU IF I
IF I CAN JUST SAY I'VE SENT TO
THAT FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
THE DEPARTMENT THAT'S BEEN MADE.
HE DID LEE CLEAR FROM THE
LEGISLATURE THAT YOU WANT THE
DEPARTMENT TO WORK YOU WANTED TO
WORK EFFECTIVELY AND YOU'RE
WAITING FOR US. TO BRING TO YOU
EITHER OF COMPREHENSIVE PROBLEM
STATEMENT OR PROPOSED SOLUTIONS
AND SO WE NEED TO GET TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
WE DO HAVE A SENSE OF URGENCY
ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
AND THANK YOU FOR THE DETAILED
RESPONSES SO --
FROM THE DEPARTMENT BEFORE WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT --
I WANT TO OBSERVE WHAT MAY HAVE
BEEN OBVIOUS TO SOME OR ALL OF
YOU AND THAT'S THE FACT THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IS NOT HERE TODAY --
THAT IN FACT BECAUSE BY DESIGN
WE WANTED TO FOCUS ON THE
DEPARTMENT --
AND AND HAVE YOU --
HERE TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
DIRECTLY --
AND YET DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
A BIG PIECE OF THE PUZZLE A BIG
PIECE OF THE SAUSAGE MAKING THAT
HAPPENS HERE AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS AND YOU KNOW
WITHOUT GOING INTO A LOT OF
DETAIL --
WHAT WE FROM YEAR TO YEAR --
WHAT DEPARTMENTS --
CAN AND CAN'T DO --
ARE AS MUCH A REFLECTION OF WHAT
COMES OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT AS
IT IS A REFLECTION OF THE ENTIRE
BUDGET AND MOVING PIECES AROUND --
AND YOU KNOW FRANKLY THAT CAN
CAN BE VERY FRUSTRATING WHEN YOU
ARE FOCUSED ON FIXING A PROBLEM.
BUT PROVERBIAL --
SO RECOGNIZE THAT AND I DON'T
WANT -- TO
SUGGESTS THAT --
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS --
THAT PART OF THE PROCESS SO
THANK YOU AGAIN --
FOR FOR BEING HERE I WOULD --
ALSO POINT OUT THAT --
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD --
OBVIOUSLY WE ARE INFORMED BY --
WHAT EXISTS TODAY AMPLE AT BY
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THE PAST --
BUT WE NEED TO BE LOOKING
FORWARD AND TO DOING THE HARD
WORK OF FOR A REDRESSING WHAT IS
A VERY --
SERIOUS STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS --
WITH WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT AND
YOU HAVE FOR YOU ON ACHIEVING A
FAVOR ALL OF THESE ISSUES SO --
THANK YOU AGAIN AND WILL NOW
PROCEED TO HEAR --
FROM --
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC --
NOBODY'S UP YES PEOPLE ARE.
GAP IF YOU WOULD STEP FORWARD TO
THE MICROPHONE --
WILL BE HAPPY TO HEAR FROM YOU
[inaudible]
GOING.
DON'T BE SHY.
A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS INGRID
RESTAURANT I'M WITH THE CENTER
ON RACE POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND I BEEN WORKING ON THE TNC
ISSUES FOR MANY YEARS
SPECIFICALLY WITH AN EYE TOWARD
RESIDENTS.
WHO LIVE NEAR HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES AND RESIDENTS WHO
LIVE NEAR CLEAN UP SITES --
I HAD HEARD A LOT ABOUT SOME OF
THESE FISCAL ISSUES BEFORE.
BUT I THINK IT CAME.
IT CAME CLOSER TO HOME WHEN I
HEARD ABOUT PROGRAM CUTS.
AND I WANT TO REITERATE FOR THIS
BOARD THAT ANY CUTS TO PROGRAMS
THAT PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH.
WILL NOT RESULT IN OLD MCAT COST
SAVINGS IT'LL MERELY.
SHIFTED THOSE COST BURDENS TO
RESIDENTS WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED IN TERMS OF HIGHER
HEALTHCARE COSTS --
HIGHER SCHOOL ABSENTEEISM LOWER
PRODUCTIVITY.
AND AS A STATE WE SUBSCRIBE TO
THE POLLUTER PAYS PRINCIPLES.
AND WE MUST LOOK AT FEE REFORM
IN A WAY THAT ULTIMATELY REDUCES
THE GENERATION OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE AND ENSURES THAT THOSE
THAT ARE PROFITING FROM THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT ARE
THE ONES THAT --
ALTERNATELY COVERING FULLY.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE.
CONTINUING TO THROW MONEY AT
THIS AGENCY YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
TO CLOSE THOSE LOOP.
SHORTFALLS.
IF.
THE LEGISLATURE DOES BAILOUT DTS
SEE AGAIN THIS YEAR IT MUST TO
DO SO WITH STRINGS ATTACHED.
IT MUST CREATE AN OVER A STRONG
IN PERMANENT OVERSIGHT BODY AND
STRONG CONCRETE BENCHMARKS THAT
WE CAN THAT ARE MEASURABLE AND
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DETAILS HE'S MAKING
MOVEMENTS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTIONS.
AND IF THESE BENCHMARKS CONTINUE
NOT TO BE MET WE HAVE TO HAVE
REAL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
FUTURE OF THIS AGENCY AND THE
NEED PERHAPS TO COMPLETELY.
REVISIT HOW WE MANAGE HAZARDOUS
WASTE IN CALIFORNIA AND AS A
WITH AN EYE TOWARD POLLUTION
PREVENTION AND HAZARDOUS WASTE
REDUCTION.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S KRISTINA WHITNEY
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
SOLAR PEAVEY INDUSTRY.
AND THE REASON I'M HERE TODAY IS
BECAUSE IN SENATE BILL FORTY
NINE IN SECTION SEVENTEEN D. TSC
HAS CLASSIFIED SOLAR PANELS AS
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND THAT IS NOT.
THE CASE THEY ARE NOT HAZARDOUS
WASTE THERE IS ONE COMPANY IN
THE INDUSTRY OUT OF THOUSANDS OF-MANUFACTURERS.
THAT DOES HAVE HAZARDOUS WASTE
IN THEIR SOLAR PANELS AND IN
HOUSE THEY DEAL WITH THEM AND
RECYCLE THEM IN A PROPER MANNER
KEEPING THEM OUT OF LANDFILLS.
OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE WAY THE
SENATE BILLS RIGHT NOW THAT THE
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA HAS
BECOME FRIGHTENED.
AND NOW THEY STORE THE SOLAR
PANELS.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN FILLING UP IN
PLACES LIKE UNDER BRIDGES WHERE
HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVE THEY HAVE
BEEN FOUND IN.
A SORT STORAGE FACILITIES ALLEN
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE FEEL
AS GOING TO TARNISH THE
REPRESENTS THE SEPARATIST BUT
THE NAME OF THE SOLAR INDUSTRY.
WHICH WERE GREEN INDUSTRY AND WE
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT KEEPING
THE SOLAR PANELS OUT OF
LANDFILLS.
BECAUSE IT'S CONSIDERED
HAZARDOUS WASTE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE WAY THAT THINGS ARE
WRITTEN THAT THEY CAN ONLY BE
STORED FOR THIRTY DAYS.
IT WITH THE CAN'T BE RECYCLED IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE INDUSTRY DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO WERE STOCKED WITH THE
SOLAR PANELS SO WHAT I'M GONNA
ASK YOU TO WRAP UP QUICKLY IF
YOU DON'T MIND THIS IS NOT.
REALLY RELEVANT TO THE TOPIC OF
THAT'S UNDER DISCUSSION HERE
TODAY BUT I WOULD ASK THE
DEPARTMENT IF THEY CAN GET TO
YOUR INFORMATION AND SO THAT
THEY CAN ASSIGN SOMEBODY TO
MASON AT YOU HAVE AND LOOK INTO
THIS ISSUE.
WOULD BE VERY HAPPY TO SHARE AND
WOULD ALSO ASK THEM TO LOOK AT
WASHINGTON STATE AND HOW THEY
HAVE CREATED A LOSS IN THAT
THERE HAS TO BE RECYCLING.
BEFORE.
SOLAR SOLD INTO THEIR STATE AND
IF WE GET COPIES OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING I THINK IT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL FOR CALIFORNIA AND OF
WE DON'T ACT NOW AND WE DON'T
CHANGE THE WAY THINGS ARE THANK
YOU ARE GOING TO PAY THE PRICE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
TOOK.
UP PLEASE LET'S.
KEEP UP PUBLIC COMMENT INTO A
SALIENT TO THE ISSUE THAT'S
DISCUSSED TODAY.
I'M GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS IN OF US BECAUSE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ROOM TO JUSTICE LINES AND I JUST
WANT TO REALLY ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY ME COLLEAGUES.
IN GRAND FROM THE CENTER IS PART
IN MY MEANT AND REALLY THINK THE
THE TEARS OF THE OF THIS HEARING
TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE SPACE.
WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR
OVERSIGHT FOR A LONG TIME I
THINK IT'S BEEN AT LEAST IN MY
TEN YEAR FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS
OR SO BUT I KNOW FOR A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS IN A LOT OF
RESIDENTS HAVE LIVED. FOR FOR
ACTUAL TRENDS CURRENCY OF THIS
DEPARTMENT FOR A LONG TIME AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
CRISTINA GARCIA AND SOME OF OUR
LOSE COMMITTED A AS FOR THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU HAVE MADE
BECAUSE WE'RE FEELING.
THE IMPACTS OF THE LACK OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE HAVE SEEN.
A LOT OF PROMISES BEING MADE IN
THE LAST FIVE TEN YEARS THAT
SOMETHING'S GOING TO HAPPEN
UNFORTUNATELY WAS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO ACTUALLY ACTIVATE
SOME MEMBERS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THIS FOR A LONG TIME
TO ACTUALLY BE HERE.
BECAUSE THEY SAID WHY.
WE HAVE BEEN I'VE BEEN IT.
YOU KNOW PROCESS AND AUDITS AND
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THIS AND THAT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING.
AND I THINK THE THE ISSUE OF
TRUST ISRAEL.
AND AND FOR US IS REALLY INSTEAD
YOU KNOW INSTEAD OF SAYING LIKE
WELL HOW CAN WE JUST FIX THIS
YEAR'S HOW DO WE FIX THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND REALLY LOOK AT THE
DEPARTMENT AS A STRUCTURAL NEED
OF LOOKING AT EVERY PROGRAM AND
SEEN WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
FUNCTIONING AND WILL PROGRAMS
ARE NOT FUNCTIONING WITHIN THIS
PARLIAMENT.
AND HOW CAN WE ARE TO REBUILD
THE DEPARTMENT FROM BOTTOM UP.
BECAUSE IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
USING THIS DEPARTMENT TO I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CARRY THE
MISSION OF LOOKING OUT ARE WAIST
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO DO THIS
NOW IN GIVEN NEVER CAN ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO CONTROL THE WE THINK
HEALTH.
POIGNANT AND BEING ABLE TO
ACTUALLY SEE WHAT WE DO FROM THE
LIFE CYCLE OF PRODUCTION OF
WASTE AND ACTUALLY DISPOSABLE WE
SEE HOW IS THAT GOING TO LOOK
LIKE.
IN THE NEXT TEN TO TWENTY YEARS
IN THE MORNING HOW IT'S
ORGANIZED NINE EXHAUSTED WITH
THE CURRENT CONDITIONS ARE
COMMUNITIES ARE CURRENTLY FACING.
IN SOME OF THE SITES.
AND FROM THERE IS WHAT ARE WE
GONNA BUILT TO ACTUALLY SEE THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY BRING COMMUNITY
VOICES INTO THESE PLANS BECAUSE
I NEVER HEARD.
FROM THE STRATEGIC PLAN THAT'S
BEING DEVELOPED HOW THEY'RE
GETTING GAUGING THE COMMUNITIES
TO ACTUALLY BE BUILT THE PLANT
TOGETHER.
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES ACTUALLY I'VE BEEN
LOOKING.
IT'S A LITTLE SEE THAT A PLAN IS
BEING CREATED WITHOUT HAVING THE
COMMUNITY ACTUALLY HAVE INPUT IN
THAT PLAN.
SIR REALLY ENCOURAGE WAIT YOU
KNOW SECRETARY BLOOM VOTE
INDICATED THIS MORNING IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
FROM ADMINISTRATION FOR A LONG
TIME.
AND WE REALLY HOPE THAT MOVING
FORWARD AT THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO
ACTUALLY DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
JUST BECAUSE FOR US IS HOW DO WE
ACTIVATE ENCOURAGE OUR MEMBERS
TO ACTUALLY BE ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE PROCESS
WHERE THE PROCESS HAS NEVER DONE
ANYTHING FOR THEM FOR THE LAST
TWENTY OR SO YEARS.
AND YOU KNOW AND I WOULD LIKE TO
REPEAT WILL BE A SUMMER CRISTINA
GARCIA SAID.
LET'S NOT REPEAT EXCITES BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER SITES
BEING CONSIDERED SIMILAR TO
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN EXCITING WE
JUST ONE ACTUALLY PREVENT.
ANYTHING EQUIVALENT TO HUSBAND
HAPPEN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
THOSE COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING THE IMPACTS OF THE
LACK OF REALLY OVERSIGHT OF ON
THIS DEPARTMENT AND WITHOUT ARE
REALLY WILL --
LOVE CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN SPECIALLY WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY MOVE FOR THE NEXT YEAR
TO ACTUALLY SEE MORE --
IN IN MORE --
ACTION ITEMS AT AND CAN ACTUALLY
TRANSLATE TO REAL SOLUTIONS ON
THE GROUND IN WITHOUT I REALLY
THINK AGAIN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
OUR TESTIMONY ON WHAT WERE SEEN
AND MORE THAN ANYTHING HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY PROVIDE SOLUTIONS THANK
YOU.
OR NOT OTHERS WE NOTICED ABOUT
ABOUT ACOSTA NOVA SWEET IF IN
SAUDI TYPICALLY CENTER THAT I
SUPPORTERS SAY ANYTHING MANY
AGAIN.
HE THE MODEST CAPITAL TITLES
THAT IS SEEN IN THE LEGISLATION.
THE SENTIMENT I WANT TO LIMóN
BEFORE.
SO DIMPLE CLOSE.
I DO THAT SO AGAIN MY NAME IS I
LOVE BUT IT'S GOT SOME OF MY
WORK AT THE SAN ANDREAS PART IN
THE ENVIRONMENT UNLESS YOU
POLICY ADVOCATE AND I DO THAT TO
PROVIDE YOU ON EXAMPLE.
ABOUT COMMUNITIES IT OR NOT
EFFECTIVELY OUT REACH TO ENGAGED
IN A CONSISTENT MANNER THERE'S A
REAL DEEP FRUSTRATION ACROSS THE
STATE AND I TRAVEL TO MANY THESE
COMMUNITIES WITH THEIR TO
PARAMOUNT AND GO ON CENTRAL
VALLEY.
WHERE THEY DO NOT GET THE
INFORMATION THAT IS?
ACCESSIBLE TO THEM IN A
CONSISTENT MANNER AND WHEN THEY
FIND OUT THAT THEY'RE BEING
POISONED.
THERE'S NO FOLLOW UP ANYONE
THERE IS ENFORCEMENT THERE'S NO
FOLLOW UP WITH THEM AND THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT RECOURSE IS THEY
HAVE OR WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TO IMPROVE THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE
THE HEALTH.
AND SO I JUST ONE SECOND.
COLLEAGUES SAID AND JUST PROVIDE
YOU ON EXAMPLE --
OF ANOTHER DEFICIT THAT THE
AGENCY CAN CAN PROVIDE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PULLING A TAURUS AT THE CENTER
ON RACE POVERTY THE ENVIRONMENT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ADVOCATE FOR
STRONG OVERSIGHT BODY AT DTS SEE.
ME THE BUDGET ISSUE ALONE IN THE
BUDGET SHORTFALL IS IS REASON
ENOUGH RATE TO SUPPORT THE NEED
FOR STRONG OVERSIGHT BODY IN
MORE TRANSPARENCY AT THIS.
AT THE TSC.
BUT MORE SIGNIFICANTLY OUT IS
THE ISSUE WE WORK WITH CMP WORKS
OF FOLKS.
AND KERN COUNTY WHO ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES IN.
THE TNC ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
PERMITS HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES.
ASSISTANT SIX DO NOT LIE HOST
COMMUNITY NOT LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR.
AND DETAIL SEE HAS
SYSTEMATICALLY FAILED OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES I'M
PERMITTING WAY SITES AND FORCING
WAY SIZE AND CLEANING UP WAY
SITES.
HOWEVER DESPITE ALL OF THAT
DETAILS HERE MEANS ONE OF THE
FEW REGULATORY BODIES WITH NO
OVERSIGHT OR GOVERNING BODY WITH
THE VERY PEOPLE SUFFERING FROM
THE HARMS.
I'M FROM THESE HOW PUBLIC HEALTH
HARMS CAN RAISE CONCERNS IN A
PUBLIC FORUM.
AS REPRESENTATIVE OF COMMUNITY
GROUPS IMPACTED IN KERN COUNTY
WE URGE THE CREATION OF A STRONG
OVERSIGHT BODY DGSE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF GETTING --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LUCY A
MARKET IS I'M HERE REPRESENTING
CAUSES CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE
UNITED FOR SUSTAINABLE ECONOMY --
BASED OUT OF INSURANCE AND
BARBARA COUNTY --
WE HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH A
HAD THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ALLIANCE TO ADDRESS THE
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT OF
DTS SEE --
IN THE COUNTRY IN THE CENTRAL
COAST WE HAVE BEEN CONCERNED
WITH THE REGULATION OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE HELLO CO.
A METAL RECYCLING FACILITY WHICH
OPERATED NEAR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN OXNARD.
AN ALREADY OVER BURDENED
COMMUNITY OF POLLUTION AND TOXIC
WASTE --
WITHOUT CONCERNS OF WHAT THE THE
IMPACTS OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH --
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED A
STRONG OVERSIGHT BODY --
MORE TRANSPARENCY AND MARK BOARD
THAT ENSURES AGENCIES MEETING
IT'S NECESSARY MANDATE --
WE SUPPORTED --
WE SUPPORT THE POLLUTER PAYS
PRINCIPLE ON THE STATE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO SUBSIDIZE SUBSIDIZED
COSTS THAT SHOULD BE COVERED BY
THE REGULATED INDUSTRY --
WE NEED FREE --
FOR FEE REFORM TO CLOSE THESE
DEFICITS AND MAKE THESE MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN
AND SO ARE COMMUNITIES HAVE
SUFFERED ENOUGH FOR THE MISTAKES
OF DC DTS SEEING IT'S TIME.
THAT -- THEY
TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THANK YOU.
HI THANK YOU OF MY NAME IS
SYLVIA OUT OF THE LITTLE AND I
AM A I'M HERE REPRESENTING
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT WHICH IS IN
HUNTINGTON PARK --
IN SOUTHEAST OUT LOS ANGELES
THAT'S NEAR THE EXITE FACILITY
AND SO FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS
FOR MYSELF.
BEING A STAKEHOLDER IN
HUNTINGTON PARK YOU KNOW I'VE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM RESIDENTS ON
OF YOU KNOW THAT LACK OF TRUST
THAT THEY HAVE WOULD DETAILS SEE
THE LACK OF OVERSIGHT --
NO TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SO REALLY
HERE TO JUST HANNAH AN ECHO WHAT
I HEAR FROM OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS --
AND ECHO WHAT FOLKS HAVE SAID
BEFORE ME AS WELL AND SO WE DO
NEED TO HAVE A CONCRETE --
HAVE CONCRETE BENCHMARKS AND A
STRONG BOARD TO ENSURE THAT DE
TSC MEETS MANDATE.
WE NEED TO MAINTAIN PROGRAMS
THAT PROTECT IN THE COMMUNITIES
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING IN A
NEXT TO A AND YOU KNOW SHARING
FENCE LINE SOMETIMES WITH THESE
HAVE THIRTY HAZARDOUS FACILITIES.
WE NEED POLLUTERS TO PAY FOR FAR
TOO LONG OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN PAYING WITH THEIR LIVES.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN PAYING FOR
DTS THESE FAILURE --
TO HAVE TRUE OVERSIGHT AND RIGHT
IMPROPERLY REGULATE THESE
FACILITIES.
WE NEED FEE REFORM AND THIS MUST
HAPPEN SO THAT WE CAN CLOSE THE
DEFICIT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME SHEENA
ROBINSON I'M WITH THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK --
AND I JUST LIKE TO ECHO SOME OF
THE POINTS OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE CALIFORNIA VINYL JUSTIN'S
ALLIANCE HAVE MADE --
A PEN WORKS IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HOME TO
HUNDREDS OF HAZARDOUS WASTE
SITES.
ALONG WITH TO SUPERFUND SITES --
AND MANY OF THESE SITES HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS RICHMOND IS ALSO 80%
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MOSTLY
WORKING CLASS AND IT'S THIS KIND
OF COMMUNITY THAT'S BEEN HEAVILY
BURDENED.
BY JUST THE SHEER AMOUNT OF
TOXIC WASTE SITES --
AND SOME OF THEM ARE OPEN AIR --
RESIDENTS EVEN REFERRED TO A
LARGE WHEN HIS TRASH MOUNTAIN
THAT AFFECTS THE RESPIRATORY --
HEALTH IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD THERE
ARE ENDS --
WHICH IS ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
A PEN WAS FOUNDED DECADES AGO
THE CONTINUE TO THIS DAY --
ALONG WITH --
DOCTORS MEDICAL CENTER WHICH WAS
THE THE YOU PUBLIC HOSPITAL
SERVING THE COMMUNITY CLOSED IN --
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND SO IF WE
DON'T HAVE STRONG PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT OF OF THE THE
PROCESSES THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
COMMITTEE KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE --
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP CONTINUING
TO SUFFER AT THE HEALTH IMPACTS
IN THE STATE IS GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY FOR THESE HEALTH BACK
IMPACTS.
IN OTHER WAYS AND SO I'M HERE TO
JUST ADVOCATE FOR STRONG SUPPORT
OF A ROBUST --
OF A DEPARTMENT THAT IS OVER TO
TAKE CARE OF THESE PROBLEMS --
WITH STRONG COMMUNICATION MINUTE
OVERSIGHT AS WELL FUNDED --
AND THAT HELPS --
INSURE THAT POLLUTERS PAY --
TO REMEDY THESE INSTEAD OF THE
PUBLIC THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEE
SAID VAN FLEET I'M FROM BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CENTER FOR RACE
POVERTY IN ENVIRONMENTS.
AND ALSO SAY THAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AT REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT ARE
GENERATED.
THAT THEN BECOME THE HAZARDOUS
WASTE AND SO IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE
NOT CUTS. TO THE SIGNATURE
PROGRAM OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TALK TROLL THE GREEN CHEMISTRY
ACT ON THE SAFER CONSUMER
PRODUCTS PROGRAM BECAUSE THAT IS
AT LEAST A START AT TRYING TO
REDUCE THE TOXIC CHEMICALS THAT
GET INTO PRODUCTS THAT END UP IN.
THE BATTERIES AND THE BRAKE PADS
AND OTHER ITEMS [inaudible]
BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT THE BUDGET
DEFICIT IS SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE URGENTLY ADDRESSED.
AND THE FACT THAT THIS IS
ALREADY GOING ON FOR FIVE YEARS
DURING THAT TIME WHERE THERE WAS
A TRANSITION TO AN ACCOUNTING
SYSTEM IS.
A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF THE NEED FOR
MORE CAREFUL MORE CONTINUOUS A
MORE REGULAR OVERSIGHT OF THE
DTS CITY.
SO WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
REFORMS THAT THE NEWS SECRETARY
WANTS TO BRING ABOUT --
THE BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS ADVOCATES THAT THERE IS
A BODY THAT REGULARLY AND MORE
IN DEPTH DIGS INTO THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE DTS SEE AN
IT'S FISCAL SITUATION.
WE SUPPORT THE POLLUTER PAYS
PRINCIPLE.
AND THINK THAT.
IF COST RECOVERY IS ONLY
STARTING TO HAPPEN NOW AND IS
NOT RETROACTIVE TO A LOT OF
COMPANIES THAT HAVE INCURRED
THESE STEPS WE WILL NOT BE
SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BILL ALLEY --
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP --
WERE HEARTENED BY THE STANCE
TAKEN BY THE NEW SECRETARY.
AND ALSO BY THE CURRENT
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEPARTMENT
THAT I THINK WE'LL.
SEE WHERE WE STAND THREE YEARS
FROM NOW OFFERS STILL WORRIED
ABOUT THE SAME THINGS SO IT'S
HEARTENING BUT WE'LL SEE.
ALSO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY
DOCTOR QUIRK ABOUT NOT LETTING
THIS PART BE CUT.
THINGS WILL ONLY GET WORSE --
I THINK CENTERS STONE KIND OF
FORCE --
TODAY WHICH WAS THE FEE
STRUCTURE AND WHEN YOU HEAR
ABOUT NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
STRUCTURE THAT STILL EXISTS
TODAY AND CLEARLY BROKEN --
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT EQUITY AND
WHO IS PAYING WE ARE TOO AND WE
THINK THE POLLUTERS SHOULD PAY
AND CLEARLY THIS IS GOING TO BE.
A PRIMARY --
THING GOING FORWARD ONE LAST
THING IS ON THE FENCE LINE
COMMUNITIES AND WHETHER THERE
REALLY BEING AFFECTED I HARKEN
BACK TO THE ALANKO OIL WELL IN
LOS ANGELES WHERE PEOPLE
COMPLAINED FOR YEARS ABOUT BEING
SECOND NO ONE BELIEVED HIM.
UNTIL USEPA ACCOMPANYING DARKER
OFFICIALS THERE COST SIX
THEMSELVES ON SITE AND FINALLY
SOMETHING WAS DONE.
SO PEOPLE ARE DARK
HYPOCHONDRIAC'S THEY ARE REALLY
GETTING HEADACHES AND NOSE
BLEEDS AND BIRTH DEFECTS
ETCETERA ALSO WE HAVE EXCITE IS
THE MAYBE ONE OF THE ULTIMATE
EXAMPLES OF WHAT HAPPENS IF.
YOU LET EXTERNALITIES CISCO AND
GO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THAT LEADS ME TO THE POOL --
POLLUTION PREVENTION PROGRAM WE
THINK SHOULD BE RESTORED AT THE
AGENCY TO AVOID THINGS LIKE THIS
IN THE CRADLE --
TO CRADLE OF THING IS VERY
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF GOING FOR
AND REFORMING THE DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANDREA
EVAN TURNER I'M WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION.
AND I CAME HERE TODAY TO STAND
UP FOR OUR ORGANIZATION CLEAN
WATER ACTION TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE COMMUNITIES
AT THE FENCE LINE WHO.
ARE PAYING THE THE PRICE --
FOR FOR THE NOT ONLY THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE BUT SOME OF THE
MISMANAGEMENT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TODAY I'VE BEEN
LUCKY -- MY
DAY TO DAY WORK HAS BEEN LAKE
CANDLE IN THIS DARK TUNNEL THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM
THAT DESPITE ITS.
CHALLENGES HAS BEEN TRANSPARENT
AND AND YOU KNOW WE CAN SEE SOME
PROGRESS THERE --
BUT OTHER EXPERIENCES WITH
DETAILS SHE HAS ALSO SHOWED OUR
ORGANIZATION SOME CULTURAL
ISSUES.
WE TO BELIEVE IN OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY IN POLLUTER PAY AND
WE SUPPORT.
THAT MOVING FORWARD BUT I HAVE
TO TELL YOU THAT WHAT I'VE ALSO
WITNESSED IS TWO MONTHS --
pRESPONSIBLE PARTY CALLING THEM
OUT ON A VIOLATION I'VE SEEN A
RELUCTANCE. TO ACTUALLY ENFORCE
THE LAW IT'S ONE THING TO
NEGOTIATE WITH AN INDUSTRY TO
TRY TO BRING THEM INTO
COMPLIANCE IT'S ANOTHER THING TO
DO THAT FOR TWO YEARS AND NEVER
ENFORCED THE LAW THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE.
HAS PASSED SO I THINK WE WE NEED
TO LOOK AT SOME CULTURAL CHANGES
SOME STRUCTURAL CHANGES
EVERYTHING YOU'VE HEARD SO FAR
FROM -- ARE
EACH A AND OTHER NGOS HERE WE
WOULD ECHO AND WE THANK YOU FOR
THIS HEARING WE THANK THE
LEADERSHIP FOR PAYING ATTENTION
TO THIS AND LOOKING FOR CHANGE
AND WE WILL.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
IN THREE YEARS AS MISSED ALLEY --
SAID WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME THINGS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS.
IN THE CALL FOR GREATER
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF THE DEPARTMENT --
WE SUPPORT EFFORTS TO
IMMEDIATELY ADDRESS THE GROWING
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AT THE
DEPARTMENT SO THEY CAN
ADEQUATELY FULFILL THEIR MANDATE
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
BY POLLUTING PREVENTION OR BY
PRESSING POLLUTION OUT WHENEVER
POSSIBLE BY CLEANING UP A WASTE
WHEN IT'S GENERATED AND BY
REGULATING IT AND EFFECTIVE
MANNER --
MUCH OF THE SITUATION
SURROUNDING ACCESS EFFORT AT RTC
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THE SANTA
SUSANA FIELD LAB PROJECT FOR
OVER TWO DECADES --
THAT WE HEARD SENATOR STERN TALK
ABOUT AND WITH HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE LIVING WITHIN TEN MILES
OF THIS FACILITY IN AND AS ONE
OF THE MOST CONTAMINATED SITES.
IN THE STATE WE THINK FINANCIAL
AND STRUCTURAL REFORM --
IMMEDIATELY IS IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURE THOROUGH CLEANUP BUT ALSO
FULL COMPLIANCE WITH THE TWENTY
TEN AGREEMENT WITH THE STATE --
I'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS BY
EWG AND CLEAN WATER ACTION AND
SAY THAT ENERGY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS STATES INNOVATIVE
GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM --
IT HAS TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL TO
ADDRESS THE TOXICITY OF
CHEMICALS AND CONSUMER PRODUCTS --
UP FRONT RATHER THAN AFTER THE
FACT -- BUT
THE PROGRAM IS FALLING SHORT AS
YOU HEARD IN THE HEARING LAST
WEEK AND WHILE SOME OF THIS --
IS DUE TO STRUCTURAL BARRIERS
THAT WERE WORKING SEPARATELY TO
ADDRESS THE LEGISLATION CENTER
ON THIS YEAR IT'S ALSO BECAUSE
OF INADEQUATE FUNDING.
AND WE THINK BETTER AND AND MORE
RESOURCES ARE NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS UP THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
CHEMICALS AND PRODUCTS OUT AHEAD
OF TIME INSTEAD OF AFTER THE
FACT AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU --
ON SUSTAINABLE FUNDING AND
BETTER PERFORMANCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT THIS YEAR THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS PHIL
TELECOMMUTE CHIEF COMPLIANCE
OFFICER CLEAN HARBORS SAFETY
CLEAN.
WE OPERATE FOURTEENTH TREATMENT
STORAGE AND DISPOSAL FACILITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT NO WE COLLECT THIRTY MILLION
GALLONS OF USED MOTOR OIL
CONVERTED INTO RENEWABLE.
MOTOR OIL IT'S USED IN ALL OF
OUR CARS AND TRUCKS SO WE HAVE A
VERY VESTED INTEREST IN MAKING
SURE THE DETAILS HE IS
SUCCESSFUL.
AND THEY'RE HELD ACCOUNTABLE OF
COURSE BUT I THINK YOU NEED TO
HEAR SOMETHING FROM UP PERMIT
TEASE POINT OF VIEW.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORK VERY
CAREFULLY.
AT LEAST FOR OUR COMPANIES IN
OUR IN OUR FACILITIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT WERE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO PERMITTING.
THEY WORK WITH US TO TRY TO
STREAMLINED PERMITTING FOR
STANDARDIZED A BNC FACILITIES.
MOST OF WHICH COLLECT USE MOTOR
ALL.
AND I THINK THEY'RE TO BE GIVEN
A CHANCE TO REBUILD THEMSELVES.
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD IS IT IS AN
ACTION ORIENTED INDIVIDUAL.
I THINK HE'LL DO A GREAT JOB
OVER THE DEPARTMENT.
I DO ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO BE INVOLVED.
IN IN DISCUSSION.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT THEY GET THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED BECAUSE WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF PERMITTING WE WANT PERMITS
PERMITS ALLOW US PREDICTABILITY.
WE HAVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
FACILITIES IN UNITED STATES.
THAT ARE UNDER PERMITS BY STATE
AND LOCAL AGENCIES WE WANT THE
PERMITS BECAUSE THEY HELP TO
BUILD A FOUNDATION OF SUPPORT.
AND RESPECT WITH THE COMMUNITY
ALLOWS US TO DO MORE OUTRAGE.
SO I HOPE THAT YOU'LL FIND A WAY
TO PROVIDE THEM WITH BRIDGE
FUNDING CITY CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE CHANGES.
THAT THE NEED TO MAKE AND I
GOTTA SAY THEY'VE HIRED A LOT OF
YOUNG.
VERY ENERGETIC.
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS THERE
AT A PLACE RIGHT NOW WITH THE
NEED TO BE TO MAKE PROGRESS.
SO CALLED FOR TO WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
THE IMPROVEMENT THAT I'M SAYING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S MY
CLAIBORNE M. IN TURN AN ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
WE AT LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WORK
ALONGSIDE ACTED COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AND EAST COACHELLA VALLEY --
THESE OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT --
MORE REFERENCE BY SECRETARY
BLUMENFELD EARLIER TODAY
COMMUNITIES THAT FEEL LEFT
BEHIND BY D. SEE.
AND THAT WANT STRONGER OVERSIGHT
AND QUICKER CLEAN UP OF
POLLUTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS.
COMMUNITIES LIKE JANE ADAMS IN
THE REVERSE TRIANGLE AND CENTRAL
IN WEST FRESNO --
THAT HAVE INDUSTRIAL LAND USES
THAT ARE INCOMPATIBLE TO NEXT
DOOR RESIDENTIAL LAND USES.
AND OUR SCHOOLS.
US SO WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
OUR COLLEAGUES WITH SE HA.
AND THE OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS WHO SPOKE
TODAY AND WE ARE TO THIS BODY TO
AGGRESSIVELY OVER C. D. TSC IN
ORDER TO INSURE PROMPT.
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEANUP COST
RECOVERY AND EFFECTIVE POLLUTION
PREVENTION THANK YOU. FIVE MORE
IN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY.
WE AGREE WITH WHAT OTHERS HAVE
COME UP HERE AND SAID OZ AND
SPECIALLY THAT TEDIOUS YOU MUST
MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND TRANSPARENT
TO IS COMMUNITIES.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH AND EIGHTIES HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING AND THESE IMPACTS
ARE ONLY EXACERBATED BY DTS SEES
AN ABILITY TO ADEQUATELY PERFORM
ITS FUNCTIONS.
WE URGE FOR ACTION THE WILL
PROVIDE FOR MORE ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS DEPARTMENT
SPECIFICALLY WE REQUEST THAT YOU
FOLLOW THE ADVICE OF THE DTS THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL.
THAT RECOMMENDED THAT A
GOVERNING BORDER OVERSIGHT BODY
BE ESTABLISHED WITHIN DTS CA TO
HELP ENSURE GREATER TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND REGULARLY MONITOR THE STATUS
OF DTS HE'S PERFORMANCE
INITIATIVES AND DECISION MAKING.
ACCORDING TO THE RP THIS IS
POSSIBLE CONSIDERING THE SIZE OF
THE TSC IT'S HUMAN HEALTH
PROTECTION MISSION AND THE
NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED
AND CLEAN UP PERMITTING AND
ENFORCEMENT WORK FOR PROJECTS
SUCH AS EXIDE.
WE BELIEVE THAT AN OVERSIGHT
BODY OR GOVERNING BOARD WILL
HELP THE DTS SEE INTO FILLING
ITS MANDATES THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER CANNOT
I'M A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY
COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT.
I HEARD ABOUT EXCITED FIRST IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AS A YOUTH
ORGANIZER.
IS TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND
ONLY RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN CLEAN
UP IN THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING EXIDE.
SO THAT POSES A QUESTION TO ME
WHAT ABOUT ALL THE OTHER
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED BY FOOT
BY.
PUTTING INDUSTRY.
WHEN IS THERE CLEAN UP GONNA
HAPPEN AND SO DO WE TELL
COMMUNITIES THAT WE HAVE TO THEY
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO WAIT?
OR IS THERE SOMETHING THAT DTZ
CAN DO AFFIRMATIVELY AND SO I
TAKE I HAVE GREAT CONCERN WHEN I
HEAR.
THAT IN ORDER TO MAKE UP THE
DIFFERENCE DEFICIT THAT THERE
HAS TO BE SOME CUTS --
TO THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
AND SO WHEN I'M ASKING --
FOR THE STATE AND FOR DTCS THAT
WE CAN COME TO A SOLUTION.
IN WHICH WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO UPLIFT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ENSURE PUBLIC HEALTH FOR ALL OF
THE COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO ENSURE
THAT POLLUTING.
INDUSTRIES ARE ACTUALLY MADE TO
PAY AND FINDING A WAY TO GET
THOSE FEES SO THE PROGRAMS CAN
CONTINUE ON AND WE CAN PROTECT
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE WORK AND
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT BRINGS
OUR HEARING TO A CONCLUSION I
WANNA THANK --
EVERYONE ON AND OFF THE DíAS
FOR OTHER PARTICIPATION AND TO
THE SAGA WILL CONTINUE --
WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU